Welcome back to our second drink of company picnic. I really had a good time going through the mill for this one because we got a lot of great stuff. Yes, we really did. So I'm going to kick us off with this background catch by Sarah L. in Dallas, Texas. Sarah says, I may be thinking too deep into this, and I don't know if the question or observation has already been asked, but I noticed that Michael and Holly are both wearing navy jackets. And I don't know if that was intentional or not. or if there is any symbolism in that decision.
欢迎回到我们的公司野餐第二杯特调。我真的很享受为这一期翻箱倒柜，因为我们找到了很多好东西。是的，确实如此。所以我要用萨拉·L（来自得克萨斯州达拉斯）的这条背景私信来为我们开个头。萨拉说，我可能想得有点深，我不知道这个问题或观察是不是已经有人提过，但我注意到迈克尔和霍莉都穿着海军蓝夹克。我不知道这到底是无意的，还是这个决定里面有什么象征意义。
Like even though they are not together right now and living separately, they are still thinking the same. Love you, ladies, and your podcast. Oh, Sarah. Completely intentional. I know it. We would do stuff like that all the time. And I love when people notice.
就像即使他们现在不在一起，分开居住，他们的想法还是一样的。爱你们，女士们，还有你们的播客。哦，萨拉。完全是故意的。我敢肯定。我们经常做这种事。我喜欢人们注意到这一点。
Yes. This was the care that our crew through props or wardrobe or hair or makeup or set dressing would take with our show. And I love when people notice and connect the dots. Sarah, such a great observation. And I love the idea that, yeah, they're apart, but still so connected. Well, I love this observation by Katie W. in Albany, New York, who said, My favorite scene is actually just a couple of moments. It's when Michael is with Holly before and after their skit, and he just pauses and looks at her. Those silent moments are so moving. You can see Michael yearning to tell Holly he loves her and also his fear and trepidation to do so.
是的。这就是我们的剧组通过道具、服装、发型、化妆或布景设计在我们剧中所花费的心思。我喜欢人们注意到并把这些线索串联起来。萨拉，真是个敏锐的观察。我喜欢这种想法，是的，他们分开了，但依然心连心。我很喜欢凯蒂·W（来自纽约州奥尔巴尼）的这个观察，她说，我最喜欢的场景其实只是几个瞬间。就是迈克尔在他们的幽默小品前后和霍莉在一起的那会儿，他只是停顿了一下看着她。那些无声的时刻太感人了。你能看出迈克尔渴望告诉霍莉他爱她，同时也有这么做的恐惧和忐忑。
It makes his statement at the end of the episode perfect. Exquisite acting by Steve and, as always, amazing writing and direction. P.S. Love the podcast so much. I went back and rewatch that moment that Katie's talking about. And that look that he gives her, it's so loaded. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, again, I want to say one of the things I love about our show are the quiet moments
这让他在剧集结尾时的表白变得完美。史蒂夫的演技精湛，而且一如既往，编剧和导演都太棒了。附言：非常喜欢这个播客。我回去重温了凯蒂提到的那个时刻。他给她的那个眼神，真的是意味深长。对，对。我是说，再说一次，我喜欢我们剧的一个地方就是那些安静的时刻
where we say so much without saying any words at all. Which is true life. Yes. Yes. All right. Well, this favorite moment is also one of mine. It is from Freya J. in Hibbing, Minnesota. Freya wrote in and said,
我们在其中什么话都不说却表达了那么多。这才是真实的日常生活。对。对。好了，那么这个最喜欢的时刻也是我最喜欢的时刻之一。来自明尼苏达州希宾的弗雷娅·J。弗雷娅写信来说，
My favorite episodes are The Injury, Safety Training, and Stress Relief Part 1. But my all-time top number one absolute favorite scene is from the company picnic episode. It's when Dwight is attempting to delay the volleyball game as Pam goes to the hospital by kicking the ball into the woods and then nonchalantly goes, I'll get it. And he turns and casually walks towards the woods. Every single time I am crying, laughing, and it'll take about five minutes for me to recover. Even thinking about the scene makes me, as Angela says, so tickled.
我最喜欢的剧集是《工伤》、《安全培训》和《压力缓解》第一部分。但我有史以来排名第一、绝对最喜欢的场景来自公司野餐那一集。就是当帕姆去医院时，德怀特试图通过把球踢进树林来拖延排球比赛，然后若无其事地说，我去捡。接着他转身漫不经心地朝树林走去。每一次我都笑得前仰后合，大约需要五分钟才能缓过来。光是想到这个场景，就让我像安吉拉说的那样，开心得不行。
And I've been giggling as I type this. Love both you ladies so much. And the whole crew of office ladies, your show feels like such a warm hug that I never want to end. And then Freya put little heart emojis. Frea, every time Dwight kicks that ball, there's just part of it that is rain. It is when I watch it and it cracks me up. Yes. Because he can be braddy like that.
我一边打字一边咯咯地笑。非常喜欢你们两位女士。还有办公室女士的整个剧组，你们的节目就像是一个永远不想结束的温暖拥抱。然后弗雷娅发了小爱心表情符号。弗雷娅，每次德怀特踢那个球，总有一部分它是纯粹的笑点。每当我看的时候，它都会让我捧腹大笑。是的。因为他有时候就是会像个被宠坏的孩子一样。
You know what I mean? Totally. Yeah. Totally. Well, we also got a letter from Jennifer C in Colorado Springs, Colorado and several other folks who wrote in to say that this episode of Company Picnic is the last episode that features Stanley's wife, Terry. And they would like to know more about the afternoon. actress who played her. Well, everyone, Terry was played by Joanne Carlson, and she was in five episodes
你知道我的意思吗？完全是。对。完全是。我们还收到了来自科罗拉多州科罗拉多斯普林斯的詹妮弗·C以及其他几位朋友的信，他们写信来说《公司野餐》这一集是斯坦利的妻子特里出场的最后一集。他们想了解更多关于扮演她的女演员的信息。好吧，各位，特里由乔安妮·卡尔森饰演，她出演了《办公室》的五集
of the office. Her character's full name is Terry Hudson, and she is Stanley's second wife. The first time we meet her is in the Dundies in season two. We see her again in Boos Cruz and Phyllis's wedding and company picnic, and then she is referenced in a few episodes as well. And, you know, Joanne, if you hear this, we would love to chat with you about your time on the office. So feel free to slide into the office ladies' Instagram DMs. Yes. That would be really fun. All right.
。她角色的全名是特里·哈德森，她是斯坦利的第二任妻子。我们第一次见到她是在第二季的《邓迪奖》中。我们在《乘游轮狂欢》、《菲利斯的婚礼》和《公司野餐》中再次看到了她，然后她在其他几集里也被提及。而且，你知道的，乔安妮，如果你听到这个，我们很乐意和你聊聊你在《办公室》的日子。所以请随时私信办公室女士的Instagram。好的。那真的会很有趣。好吧。
So lastly, Cassidy C. in Santa Clarita, California, and Patrick N. from Melbourne, Florida, wanted us to know a fun crossover. Cassidy and Patrick pointed out that in company picnic, Michael mentions to AJ and Holly that he is designing a chair, quote, it's part of your pants. You sit down.
最后，加利福尼亚州圣克拉丽塔的卡西迪·C和佛罗里达州墨尔本的帕特里克·N想让我们知道一个有趣的联动。卡西迪和帕特里克指出，在《公司野餐》中，迈克尔向AJ和霍莉提到他正在设计一把椅子，原话是“它是你裤子的一部分。你坐下来。”
You're supported. And Holly says she remembers. members his chairpants idea. Well, in the show Jury Duty by Lee Eisenberg and Gene Stepninski, Todd wears his own version and invention of chairpants. Yes, I remember seeing it. I remember watching jury duty and being like, that's Michael's idea. Yeah. So people wanted to know if this was a nod to their days on the office. And it is. A hundred percent. A hundred percent. All right, everyone. Now here is our second drink of company picnic. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kishol. We were on The Office together.
“你得到了支撑。”霍莉说她记得他关于椅子裤的想法。在由李·艾森伯格和吉恩·斯塔普尼茨基创作的剧集《陪审义务》中，托德穿着他自己版本的发明椅子裤。是的，我记得看到过。我记得看《陪审义务》的时候觉得，那是迈克尔的点子。是的。所以人们想知道这是否是在向他们在《办公室》的日子致敬。确实是的。百分之百。百分之百。好吧，各位。现在是我们的公司野餐第二杯特调。我是珍娜·费舍尔。
And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the Office Ladies. Jenna Fisher. I think I haven't met a moment. Because today in the world, the 100th episode of Office Ladies' podcast came out. Yes.
我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是好朋友。现在我们专门为你制作《办公室终极重温》播客。每周，我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。珍娜·费舍尔。我想我遇到一个值得纪念的时刻。因为今天在全世界范围内，《办公室女士》播客的第100期节目发布了。是的。
And now here we are recording our podcast. about the 100th episode of The Office. That's very meta. And our ages almost equal 100. Oh, well, why'd you have to throw that in there? I don't know. I was looking for more hundreds. All right. Well, we should get into this episode. We have so much to cover. We do. This is going to be a long one. That's what she said.
现在我们在这里录制关于《办公室》第100集的播客。这非常元叙事。而且我们的年龄加起来差不多100岁。哦，好吧，你为什么要把这个扯进来？我不知道。我在找更多的数字100。好吧。我们应该开始聊这一集了。我们要讲的内容太多了。确实。这会是很长的一期。她刚才就是这么说的。
It's Company Picnic, Season 5, Episode 28, written by Jen Salada and Paul Lieberstein, directed by the dearest man on the planet Ken Quapis. Summary, it's the Dundermifflin Company Picnic. All of them are there, all the branches. Yes, in their own special t-shirts that have their branch name on them. Oh, I have it, lady. We'll get to it. Well, the Scranton branch is going to compete against the other branches in a company-wide volleyball tournament. Meanwhile, Michael and Holly reunite to perform a comedy skit where they accidentally reveal some confidential information to the crowd. David Wallace, why would you tell Michael Scott anything of that magnitude and expect him to keep it quiet? When David introduces their skit, one of my favorite lines is when he says, I have not seen this.
这是《公司野餐》，第五季第28集，由珍·萨拉达和保罗·利伯斯坦编剧，由地球上最亲爱的男人肯·卡皮斯执导。剧情梗概，这是邓德米夫林公司的野餐。所有人都到了，所有的分公司都到了。是的，穿着印有他们分公司名字的特殊T恤。哦，我有，女士。我们等会儿会讲到。斯克兰顿分公司将与其他分公司在全公司范围内的排球锦标赛中展开竞争。与此同时，迈克尔和霍莉重聚并表演了一个喜剧小品，在小品中他们不小心向观众透露了一些机密信息。大卫·华尔兹，你为什么要把这种程度的事情告诉迈克尔·斯科特并指望他守口如瓶？当大卫介绍他们的短剧时，我最喜欢的台词之一就是他说，“我没看过这个。”
I have not seen this, yeah. Finally, Dwight is going to defend Angela's honor. Tell Rolf. Yeah. Yeah. And ultimately, an ankle injury is going to send Pam to the hospital where she and Jim get some surprising news. So sweet. I love this episode.
“我没看过这个，对。”最后，德怀特将捍卫安吉拉的荣誉。告诉罗尔夫。对。对。最终，一次脚踝受伤将帕姆送进了医院，在那里她和吉姆得到了一个令人惊讶的消息。太甜蜜了。我喜欢这一集。
Fast fact number one, company picnic was the 100th episode of The Office. Yes. This was a very big deal for the network because it meant our show was now eligible for syndication. Which I didn't even know what that meant. I thought maybe we should explain it. Okay, do. Because I remember when we hit 100, I was like, what's all the hullabaloo? Yeah, sure, we hit 100.
第一条幕后快讯，《公司野餐》是《办公室》的第100集。是的。这对电视台来说是一件大事，因为这意味着我们的节目现在有资格进行辛迪加联合播出。我甚至不知道那是什么意思。我想也许我们应该解释一下。好的，解释吧。因为我记得当我们达到100集的时候，我说，这有什么大惊小怪的？是的，当然，我们达到了100集。
That's cool. I know. Maybe, you know, we'll all go out to dinner or something. No. No. For the network, super big. They all showed up to the set. They did.
这很酷。我知道。也许，你知道，我们会一起出去吃晚饭什么的。不。不。对电视台来说，超级大。他们全都出现在片场了。他们真的来了。
They brought a cake. It was as big as like a poker table. It was humongous. It was. That's what she said. That's what she said. They brought champagne. But we couldn't drink it.
他们带了一个蛋糕。它有扑克桌那么大。它大得离谱。确实如此。她刚才就是这么说的。她刚才就是这么说的。他们带了香槟。但我们不能喝。
No, because we had to go back to work. We actually only had 15 minutes. with the cake, all said and told. It was on our lunch break. So if you wanted to eat, we had 30 minutes photo with a cake, and then we had to, like, run out the door. Well, I remember Greg gave a very nice speech about what the 100 episodes had meant to him. Entertainment Tonight was there. All the press was there. I mean, this was a super big deal. Let's tell you why. When a show hits 100 episodes and goes into syndication, it means that the network can now start selling the show in a package to different places where they can rerun it. So it doesn't just run on NBC anymore. It gets on all the cable networks.
不，因为我们得回去工作。总而言之，我们其实只有15分钟的时间来吃蛋糕。那是在我们的午休时间。所以如果你想吃东西，我们有30分钟时间跟蛋糕合影，然后我们就得，呃，冲出门去。嗯，我记得格雷格发表了一场非常精彩的演讲，讲述这100集对他意味着什么。今夜娱乐也在场。所有的媒体都在场。我的意思是，这是一件超级大的事。让我们告诉你为什么。当一部剧达到100集并进入辛迪加联合播出时，这意味着电视台现在可以开始将该剧打包出售给不同的地方，让他们重播。所以它不再只在NBC播出。它会登陆所有有线电视网。
Like Comedy Central, how it reruns on Comedy Central. Right. And guys, remember, this predates all streaming. Yes. So this was all kind of a cable thing. But this meant big money for the network. I didn't know that, but it makes sense because these other places pay them to have it. Yes. But what I think a lot of people don't know, is that the actors do not cash in on this unless they are what is called profit participants. Oh yeah. And guess what? We weren't. We were not. Now, our union, SAG, does negotiate a small fee for syndicated reruns. So it's very fun. You get checks, and they're great. They're great. But they have you guys this like cascading tier. So you get a check and you're like, woo-boo. Then the next one's a little lower, then it's a little lower, then it's a little lower, then it's a little lower, then it's a little lower. and then it's for like $2. Well, you know that bar that they have called residuals in Burbank?
比如喜剧中心频道，它是如何在喜剧中心频道重播的。没错。伙计们，记住，这比所有的流媒体出现都要早。是的。所以这在很大程度上是一件有线电视的事情。但这给电视台带来了巨额资金。我不知道这一点，但这是合情合理的，因为这些其他地方花钱买下它。是的。但我想很多人不知道的是，演员们从这里面分不到钱，除非他们被称为利润分成参与者。哦，是的。你猜怎么着？我们不是。我们不是。现在，我们的工会，SAG，确实为联合重播谈判了一笔小额费用。所以这很有趣。你会收到支票，而且它们很棒。它们很棒。但他们给你们这种像阶梯递减一样的层级。所以你收到一张支票，你会觉得，哇呜。然后下一张稍微低一点，然后低一点，然后低一点，然后低一点，然后低一点，然后低一点，最后只有2美元左右。好吧，你知道他们在伯班克开的那家叫残余（Residuals）的酒吧吗？
This is a famous bar, you guys. Yeah, so there's this bar called residuals. And if you're an actor and you bring in a residual check that's under a dollar, they'll give you a free drink and then they tack your check up on the wall. Yeah. I have a friend of mine who saved a residual check for, I think it was 17 cents, and I put it on his bulletin board. Lady, I got one for 21 cents.
这是一个著名的酒吧，伙计们。是的，所以有一家叫残余的酒吧。如果你是一个演员，你拿去一张金额不到一美元的残余支票，他们会给你一杯免费饮料，然后把你的支票钉在墙上。是的。我有个朋友留着一张残余支票，我想那是17美分，我把它贴在了他的公告栏上。女士，我收到过一张21美分的。
It costs more money. to mail it to me. Probably and to print it. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. So yeah, they were able to make a lot of money selling the show to cable and then eventually you guys, I mean, you know, they were able to sell it to all the streamers. Yeah. I guess we should probably say the actors don't get a big payout for that either. That money goes to the profit participants. See, the word profit participant is something I'd never heard of. And as it turns out, if you're one of those folks, that is. is the Shataki. Mm-hmm.
邮寄给我的邮费都要比这多。可能还有印刷费。对。对。完全正确。所以，是的，他们通过把节目卖给有线电视赚了很多钱，然后最终，伙计们，我的意思是，你知道，他们能够把它卖给所有的流媒体。对。我想我们可能应该说，演员们对此也没有得到巨额的分红。这笔钱归利润分成参与者所有。你看，“利润分成参与者”这个词是我以前从未听说过的。事实证明，如果你是那些人之一，那就是。
Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. It sure is. Angela, you found out the inspiration for our 100th episode while listening to the DVD commentary. Will you share? I will. I'm officially part of Fast Fact Number One, folks.
嗯哼。确实如此。安吉拉，你在听DVD评论音轨时发现了我们第100集的灵感来源。你能分享一下吗？我会的。各位，我正式参与了第一条幕后快讯。
Oh, yeah. Here's the thing. If you love really good DVD commentaries, this is one not to miss of the office box set, because Ken Quapas and Paul Lieberstein and Jen Salata share so many great details. They were the only three people on this commentary, and I really enjoyed it. Paul shared that the idea for the company picnic, they had it at the very beginning of season five. They always knew that they would be working towards this episode. Wow.
哦，是的。事情是这样的。如果你喜欢非常精彩的DVD评论音轨，办公室珍藏版里的这一集绝对不容错过，因为肯·卡皮斯、保罗·利伯斯坦和珍·萨拉达分享了太多精彩的细节。他们是这个评论音轨里仅有的三个人，我真的很喜欢。保罗分享说，关于公司野餐的点子，他们在第五季刚开始的时候就有了。他们一直都知道他们会朝着这一集努力。哇。
And Jen shared that they wanted to bring all of the branches together. They researched company picnics. This delighted me, because I just imagined Jen Googling company picnics. She was a lady who Googled. I was going to say, like, that would have been us. Yes. We would have been like, wait, let's research what people do. And one of the things that came up was a volleyball tournament. So they thought that would be fun. And Paul said he thought it was a great way to bring everyone back together, all the different branches, all the different characters for this big 100th episode. The only characters you don't see that were in the world of the show really were Jan, but it doesn't make sense for Jan to come back. Yes. And Karen. Yes, we got mail about that. Where was Karen? And Jen'sel. She said Rashida Jones was filming Parks and Recreation and they couldn't get her for a whole week of work to be at this picnic. And then they realized, wait, she would be on maternity leave.
珍分享说，他们想把所有的分公司聚在一起。他们研究了公司野餐。这让我很高兴，因为我刚好能想象到珍在谷歌上搜索公司野餐的样子。她是一个会用谷歌搜索的女士。我本想说，这就像是我们会做的事。是的。我们会说，等等，让我们研究一下人们都做些什么。其中出现的一项活动就是排球锦标赛。所以他们觉得这会很有趣。保罗说他认为这是让所有人重新聚在一起的绝佳方式，所有的不同分公司，所有不同的角色，为了这伟大的一百集。你在剧中唯一看不到的真正存在于这个世界中的角色是简，但简回来并不合理。是的。还有凯伦。是的，我们收到了关于这个的邮件。凯伦在哪里？还有珍·塞尔。她说过，瑞秋·琼斯当时在拍摄《公园与游憩》，他们无法让她空出一整周的时间来参加这个野餐。然后他们意识到，等等，她当时应该在产假中。
So they tracked her story-wise as being on maternity leave and that's why she wasn't there. Well, that worked out perfect. While the volleyball was a great idea, Ken did share that it was a logistical nightmare because they started filming and they were trying to keep with the rules of volleyball. Okay. Which means the teams trade sides depending on score or whatever, but they just had to bail. They had to bail because it just got too complicated. And Jen said she had this memory of looking over at Ken, and he had a clipboard, and he had a little quarter, and he was tracing this coin, you know, with a pencil and placing it
所以在剧情上他们把她的设定安排在产假中，这就是她不在那里的原因。好吧，这太完美了。虽然排球是个好主意，但肯确实分享说这是一场后勤噩梦，因为他们开始拍摄时，他们试图遵守排球的规则。好吧。这意味着球队根据比分或别的什么交换场地，但他们不得不放弃。他们不得不放弃，因为事情变得太复杂了。珍说她记忆中自己看着肯，他手里拿着一个剪贴板，拿着一枚小硬币，他用铅笔描着这个硬币的边缘，你知道的，把它放好
and mapping out where everyone was going to stand and who was serving and who was playing what position, because it was so complex to shoot. I thought it was interesting that they chose volleyball. Any company picnic I've ever been to, it's usually softball. But I do see how people are really spread out in softball. So I guess that makes sense to me. Right. But I mean, I can't even imagine.
并规划出每个人要站在哪里，谁发球，谁打什么位置，因为拍摄实在是太复杂了。我觉得他们选择排球很有意思。我去过的任何公司野餐，通常都是垒球。但我确实明白在垒球中人们的分散范围真的很大。所以我想这对我来说说得通。对。但我的意思是，我甚至无法想象。
Jen and Paul shared this other thing. Jen said that her and Paul, as they wrote this episode, they thought that each team had nine players. And so they wrote the whole script with each team having nine players. Oh, no. And then they got to the production meeting. And in the production meeting, someone was like, you know, on volleyball teams, you have six players on the court, not nine. And Paul and them were like, what? Oh, my gosh.
珍和保罗分享了另一件事。珍说她和保罗在写这一集时，他们以为每支球队有九名队员。所以他们整个剧本都是按照每支球队九名队员来写的。哦，不。然后他们去开制作会议。在制作会议上，有人说，你知道，在排球队里，场上有六名队员，而不是九名。然后保罗他们就说，什么？哦，天哪。
But, yeah, so they had to change that, like, immediately. And I have more fun tidbits from the three of them in the commentary. I'll sprinkle through the episode. All right. Angela. What? Great job on that fast fact. Oh, thank you.
但是，是的，所以他们不得不立刻改变这一点。我从他们三人的评论音轨里还有更多有趣的八卦。我会在这一集里穿插着讲。好吧，安吉拉。什么？那个幕后快讯干得漂亮。哦，谢谢你。
I really enjoyed that. Thanks so much. You told me, you were like, Jenna, there's some great stuff about the inspiration. behind the episode and I said, I'm holding a spot for you. Up in Fast Facts, lady. You did. All right. Fast fact number two is a location breakdown. Now, the signs hanging in this episode say that this picnic is being held at the Meadows in upstate New York. I could not find any information on this or if this is a real place. Hmm. Faky place. Perhaps does anyone know. Please comment on Office Ladies' Pod.
我很喜欢。非常感谢。你告诉我，你当时说，珍娜，关于这一集背后的灵感有一些很棒的内容，我说，我给你留了个位置。在幕后快讯里，女士。你确实留了。好吧。第二条幕后快讯是场景解析。现在，挂这一集里的牌子说这次野餐是在纽约州北部的米多斯（The Meadows）举行的。我找不到关于这个的任何信息，也不知道这是否是一个真实的地方。嗯。虚构的地方。也许有人知道吗？请在“办公室女士”播客评论区留言。
If you've ever been to a park called the Meadows in upstate New York, I'd love to know. Fan question, Rayon from Pakistan would like to know where did we actually film this episode? Well, we filmed at Kalamigos Ranch in Malibu Canyon. It is a beautiful location. It's kind of nestled into the side of this canyon in the Malibu Mountains. Did you know it has its own water source from a space? bring on the property. I didn't know that, but I know a lot of people get married there.
如果你去过纽约州北部一个叫米多斯（The Meadows）的公园，我很想知道。粉丝提问，来自巴基斯坦的雷安想知道我们实际上是在哪里拍摄这一集的？好吧，我们在马里布峡谷的卡拉米戈斯牧场（Kalamigos Ranch）拍摄的。这是一个美丽的地方。它有点隐匿在马里布山脉这个峡谷的侧面。你知道它有来自太空的水源吗？带在物业上。我不知道这个，但我知道很多人在那里结婚。
I've been to a wedding there. You know what? Randy Cordray knew about this location because he had been the best man at a wedding there. And when the script came up, he remembered it and suggested it to our locations manager, Kyle Alexander. And they scouted it, and they all agreed it was perfect. So now, Angela, you mentioned how Ken Kwapis said, like, this was a logistically difficult shoot.
我曾去那里参加过婚礼。你知道吗？兰迪·科德雷知道这个地方，因为他曾在那里的一场婚礼上担任伴郎。当剧本出来时，他记起了这个地方，并把它推荐给了我们的外景经理凯尔·亚历山大。他们去踩了点，并且都一致认为这里完美极了。所以现在，安吉拉，你提到了肯·卡皮斯是如何说这一集在后勤上拍摄起来很困难的。
Randy said this was a very difficult episode to pull off logistically from a production side because we had so many people. So many people and we were in the middle of a canyon. He said we had to hire additional crew including multiple medics. And we had hydration stations and sunscreen stations. And Sergio and Allen are caterers. They had to triple their staff. They had three lines to serve lunch, like three buffet. lines. And then Peter and Vartan at Crafts Service, they also had three stations instead of one.
兰迪说从制作方面来看，这一集在后勤上很难搞定，因为我们有太多人。太多人了，而且我们正处于峡谷中央。他说我们不得不雇佣额外的剧组人员，包括多名医护人员。我们有补水站和防晒霜站。我们的餐饮供应商塞尔吉奥和艾伦。他们不得不将员工人数增加两三倍。他们有三条线来供应午餐，就像三个自助餐线。然后是工艺服务部的彼得和瓦尔坦，他们也设立了三个工作站而不是一个。
It was a lot of concern about being able to feed everybody because all the background food, people were told not to eat. Yeah, it was faky food. It was real food, but it had been at various temperatures that made it sort of unsafe to eat. So if you watch the episode, you might notice no one eats anything off of their plates of food. Check it out. Ken said there was probably like 250 people there. Guess what my fast fact number three is, lady? What? I'll tell you.
有很多人担心能否喂饱所有人，因为所有的背景道具食物，大家都被告知不要吃。是的，那是假食物。那是真食物，但它一直处于各种温度下，使得它吃起来有点不安全。所以如果你看这一集，你可能会注意到没有人吃盘子里的任何食物。去看看吧。肯说那里大概有250人。你猜我的第三条幕后快讯是什么，女士？什么？我告诉你。
We had 14 guest actors, our regular cast, and 185 background performers for this episode. Also, I thought this was interesting. Some of the background performers were called special business performers. Special business? You know what their special business was? Volleyball? Yeah. Playing volleyball for hours on end.
我们这一集有14位客串演员、常规演员和185名背景演员。还有，我觉得这很有趣。一些背景演员被称为特殊业务演员。特殊业务？你知道他们的特殊业务是什么吗？排球？是的。连续几个小时打排球。
Lady, were you ever a background performer? You know it. That's how I earned my sag card. Yeah, same. Did you have any special business listed on your background performer resume? Yes, I did. What was your special business? That I could speak Indonesian.
女士，你当过背景演员吗？你知道的。这就是我赚取演员工会卡的方式。是的，一样。你的背景演员简历上列出过任何特殊业务吗？是的，我列过。你的特殊业务是什么？我会说印尼语。
Oh. Mm-hmm. My special business was water skiing, bowling, and animal handling. Oh, I also put I could play tennis and roller skate. Those are a big deal. that's a big deal. I was on 90210.10. Did you have to do any of your special business? I didn't. I was one of Tori spelling sorority sisters, but I did pass the ballots of a voting, a sorority voting session to, I handed them to Tori. Oh, you got to interact. Yes, briefly. I said nothing. I just handed some paper to her.
哦。嗯哼。我的特殊业务是滑水、保龄球和动物驯导。哦，我还写了我会打网球和轮滑。这些都是大事。这可是大事。我上过《飞越比弗利》（90210）。你必须做你的任何特殊业务吗？我没有。我是托里·斯佩林联谊会的姐妹之一，但我确实把一张投票的选票递了过去，一个联谊会投票环节，我把它们交给了托里。哦，你得到了互动。是的，简短地。我什么也没说。我只是把一些纸递给了她。
I was an extra on the movie Pleasantville starring Reese Witherspoon and Toby McGuire. And I had to play a teenager. And that was really fun because I got to dress up in old-timey clothes the whole time. But check this out. They came into the extras holding area because they needed three couples to makeout in the backseat of a car. They were going to like pan across all these different couples making out until they got to the car with the lead actors. Were you part of the makeout couples? No. You would have become a featured extra if you did it and you got a bump in pay, but I felt too shy.
我是在由瑞茜·威瑟斯彭和托比·马奎尔主演的电影《欢乐谷》里当过临时演员。我得扮演一个青少年。那真的很有趣，因为我一整天都得穿着老式的衣服。但你看这个。他们走进临时演员的休息区，因为他们需要三对情侣在汽车后座上亲热。他们打算把镜头扫过所有这些亲热的情侣，直到拍到有主演的那辆车。你是亲热情侣中的一员吗？没有。如果你做了，你就会成为特约临时演员，薪水也会上涨，但我当时觉得太害羞了。
So I didn't volunteer. But lady, we had a very special background performer on this episode of The Office, and it was Jenny Tan who runs the fan website, officetellie.com. Yes. We had all become friends with her, and she was invited to spend the entire week with us getting an exclusive look at the finale, and they asked her to be an extra. And lady, she documented all five days of shooting this episode on OfficeTelley. It is still there and she has tons of photos. Amazing. She also gave this amazing breakdown of what it was like to be a background performer on
所以我没有自告奋勇。但是女士，我们这一集的《办公室》里有一个非常特殊的背景演员，那就是运营粉丝网站officeTally.com的珍妮·谭。是的。我们都和她成为了朋友，她被邀请和我们一起度过整整一周，独家探班大结局，他们邀请她当临时演员。女士，她把拍摄这一集的全部五天都记录在了OfficeTally上。它现在还在那里，她有大量的照片。太棒了。她还对作为一名背景演员的感受进行了精彩的剖析
Company Picnic. Oh my gosh, are you going to share? Yes. You guys, Jenny was sort of someone who made a community for the office online before anyone was doing that. Before social media. Before social media. And she was there for the show providing this community in our earliest days.
《公司野餐》。哦，天哪，你要分享吗？是的。你们知道，珍妮可以说是那种在任何人都没有这样做之前在网上为《办公室》建立社群的人。在社交媒体之前。在社交媒体之前。在我们最早的日子里，她就在那里为节目提供这个社群。
when we didn't even know the future of the show, and it meant a lot to all of us. And we would reach out to her and give her, like, exclusive tips or content or photos that she would post on the website, and it became kind of the hub. Yeah. And this was before networks did any kind of social media or website for any of their shows. And our show had this presence because of Jenny. And so her documenting of our show is very extensive, and it's all still there on Office Telephone. There's all these exclusive interviews. It's amazing. She said you could really tell the people who were professional background artists because they would
当时我们甚至不知道这个节目的未来会怎样，这对我们所有人都意义重大。我们会联系她，给她提供一些独家小贴士、内容或照片，然后她会发在网站上，这里有点变成了核心枢纽。是的。这是在各大电视网为他们的任何节目做任何社交媒体或网站之前的事。我们的节目因为珍妮而有了这种存在感。所以她对我们节目的记录非常广泛，而且全部都还在OfficeTally上。那里有所有这些独家采访。太棒了。她说你真的能看出哪些人是专业的背景演员，因为他们会
bring tons of gear, like rolling luggage filled with what she said, quote, outerwear for every possible weather condition, chairs, water, snacks, something to read. It's like, you know, when you go to the beach and you see people like come with the wagon full of stuff or at the soccer game, that's a professional background. performer. Oh yeah. I remember doing background work and there was a guy that had a backpack that was a chair. Yes. And you could open the backpack and there was stuff inside or you could unfold it and sit in it. Because background performers do not get trailers. You mostly are going to be directed to a holding area with some folding chairs in it. But my experience was there were never
带一大堆装备，比如滚轮行李箱，里面装满了她所说的，引述，“适合所有可能天气状况的外套、椅子、水、零食、阅读物。”这就好像，你知道的，当你去海滩时，你看到人们带着装满东西的手推车来，或者在足球比赛上，那是专业的背景演员。哦，是的。我记得做过背景工作，有一个家伙背着一个背包，那背包是一张椅子。是的。你可以打开背包，里面有东西，或者你可以把它展开坐上去。因为背景演员没有房车。你大多会被带到一个休息区，里面有一些折叠椅。但我的经验是从来没有
enough chairs for each person. Never enough chairs and they're usually outside. Yeah. So Jenny said that when she first went to the wardrobe tent, she was given an apron to wear and she said, she would be a grill cook. But then about an hour later, production pulled her aside and made her a buffalo branch employee. And then they winked and said, you're going to be part of a special branch. But she didn't know what that meant yet. And get this. Jenny talked to a bunch of the background folks and she said that most of them were not office fans, that they had never seen the show and that a few of them did not know who Steve Carell was. She said they were thrilled to be working on our show because we had a reputation for treating background performers very, very well
每个人的椅子都不够。从来没有足够的椅子，而且它们通常在外面。是的。所以珍妮说，当她第一次去服装帐篷时，她拿到了一条围裙穿，并且她说，她将成为一名烧烤厨师。但大约一个小时后，制作组把她拉到一边，让她成为布法罗分公司的员工。然后他们眨了眨眼说，你将成为一个特殊分公司的一部分。但她当时还不知道那是什么意思。还有这个。珍妮和许多背景演员聊过，她说他们大多数都不是《办公室》的粉丝，他们从未看过这部剧，其中有几个人甚至不知道史蒂夫·卡瑞尔是谁。她说他们很高兴能在我们的节目中工作，因为我们以对待背景演员非常非常好而闻名
and for providing great food. She said one person told her, from a work perspective, to be able to be an extra on the office for an entire week, I feel like I won the lottery. So that made me really proud that our show did a good job because as a person who did a lot of background work, yeah. Yeah. It meant a lot. Usually the background performers were like the last people who get to go through the lunch line.
并且提供很棒的食物。她说有一个人告诉她，从工作的角度来看，能够在一整天里在《办公室》里当临时演员，我觉得我中了彩票。这让我感到非常自豪，因为我们的节目做得很好，因为作为一个做过大量背景工作的人，是的。是的。这意义重大。通常背景演员是排在最后吃午餐的一群人。
and it's like what's left almost nothing, and you were not allowed to go to craft services. But on our show, we had a whole buffet set aside just for the background performers and a whole craft services table that they kept full. And it was awesome. Well, you know, that's Randy Cordray. Randy took care of everyone. However you were a part of our show, he was going to make sure you were taken care of. That is absolutely true, lady.
而且就像剩下的一样，几乎什么都没有，而且你不被允许去零食区。但在我们的节目中，我们专门为背景演员准备了整个自助餐，还有一个一直保持满状态的零食台。这太棒了。嗯，你知道，那是兰迪·科德雷。兰迪照顾了每一个人。无论你是我们节目的一部分，他都会确保你得到照顾。这绝对是真的，女士。
All right, lady, those are all my fast facts. a lot. Well, it's a huge episode. I know. All right. Should we take a break and then start breaking down this episode? Just heads up. It's going to be a long one. That's what she said. We are back and the phone is ringing at reception. The lights are out. Yeah. Aaron takes the call and she says that Michael is not in right now, but he'll call this person back when he gets back. When he wakes up, I mean gets back. Right. Well, guess what? Michael is sleeping because he had chicken pot pie for lunch. Not just chicken pot pie. Jenna, he had the whole entire chicken pot pie. A family size. A family size. And he's gone to sleep, as one would do. Well, the whole office is going to
好吧，女士，这些就是我所有的幕后快讯。好多啊。嗯，这是一个很大的剧集。我知道。好吧。我们休息一下，然后开始剖析这一集怎么样？提前预告一下。这会是很长的一期。她刚才就是这么说的。我们回来了，前台的电话在响。灯都熄灭了。是的。艾伦接了电话，她说迈克尔现在不在，但他回来后会给这个人回电话。当他醒来时，我是说回来时。没错。好吧，你猜怎么着？迈克尔在睡觉，因为他午饭吃了鸡肉ポット派。不仅仅是鸡肉ポット派。珍娜，他吃了一整整个鸡肉ポット派。家庭装的。家庭装的。然后他去睡觉了，正常人都会这么做。好吧，整个办公室都要
prank Michael into thinking that it is 5 o'clock when he wakes up so that they can all go home early. And Dwight does not normally condone leaving early, but he does have that appointment with his horse doctor today, so he's in. Mm-hmm. Fan catch from Marcy G in Connecticut, there is a small detail that tickles me every time I see it. In the cold open when they're tricking a sleeping Michael into thinking it's 5 p.m., they have to change the time on his watch. Pam has her shoes off so she doesn't make noise in his office. But if you notice, Dwight also has his shoes off while he runs outside to change the time on Michael's car. I saw that. Jim also has his shoes off. I don't know. Did everyone just take their shoes off? We had another fan catch from Lloyd C from Australia, who said, during Jim's talking head, when he goes to turn the clock forward, the time starts on 1250. But when Dwight goes to Michael's car to change the time, it starts at 1210.
恶作剧迈克尔，让他以为他醒来时已经是5点钟，这样他们就可以全提早下班了。德怀特通常不同意提前离开，但他今天确实和他的马医有预约，所以他加入了。嗯哼。来自康涅狄格州的粉丝马西G的发现，有一个小细节每次我看到它都会逗乐我。在冷开场中，当他们欺骗正在睡觉的迈克尔以为已经是下午5点时，他们必须更改他手表上的时间。帕姆把鞋子脱了，这样她在他的办公室里就不会发出声音。但如果你注意到，德怀特在跑出去更改迈克尔车上的时间时也把鞋子脱了。我看到了。吉姆也把鞋子脱了。我不知道。是不是每个人都把鞋子脱了？我们还有来自澳大利亚的洛伊德C的另一个粉丝发现，他说，在吉姆的独白期间，当他去把时钟往前拨时，时间是从12点50分开始的。但当德怀特去迈克尔的车上改时间时，它是从12点10分开始的。
He said, was this a continuity gap? Or did Dwight's Panther Speed turn time backwards outside of the office? I think it was probably just a continuity catch. You know, maybe they had originally intended to see Dwight running outside to the car first and then have Jim explain it in his talking head. And then maybe they just swapped it in editing. I bet that's right, because Veda would have been all on top of this. She had everything meticulously time-coded every time we had a clock.
他说，这是一个连贯性漏洞吗？还是说德怀特的速度把办公室外面的时间给倒转了？我想这可能只是一个连贯性的失误。你知道，也许他们原本打算先看到德怀特跑出去到车里，然后让吉姆在他的独白中解释。然后也许他们只是在剪辑中把它们对调了。我敢打赌是这样的，因为维达对这些一定会抓得很紧。每次我们有钟表时，她都把时间码编得一丝不苟。
She was very, like, particular. So I feel like that was a change-up in editing. Jenny Tan, who was there that day watching us film, noted that John had a really hard time winding the clock backwards and delivering his monologue and timing it out perfectly. I thought so watching it. I'll tell you why. John is so effortless as Jim, but in this moment I could see him concentrating on that clock and just for a split second, I thought I saw John. Well, she said that the knob on the back was really, really tiny and that John kept overshooting the time.
她非常，呃，挑剔。所以我觉得那是剪辑中的一个改动。当时在那天看着我们拍摄的珍妮·谭指出，约翰把时钟往回拨并发表他的独白并把它完美地计时真的很难。我看着时。我就这么觉得。我告诉你为什么。约翰演吉姆时那么自如，但在这一刻我能看到他全神贯注于那个时钟，就在那一分一秒，我以为我看到了约翰。嗯，她说后面的那个旋钮真的非常非常小，约翰一直把时间调过头。
Like, it kept ending on, like, 515 or 510 instead of right before 5. But she said they finally got it perfect on the last take and then they stopped. They were like, we got it. Yeah, done. Well, this whole elaborate ruse ends when they all collectively, on the count of three, just erupt into laughter. And this wakes Michael up. He laughs, too, because he always wants to be in on the joke. Yes, yes.
就像，它总是停在，比如说，5点15分或5点10分，而不是刚好在5点之前。但她说他们在最后一条终于把它做得完美无瑕，然后他们停了下来。他们就像，我们搞定了。对，完成了。好吧，这个精心策划的骗局在他们所有人齐声数到三的时候集体爆发出一阵大笑而告终。这把迈克尔吵醒了。他也笑了，因为他总是想融入这个笑话里。是的，是的。
But you had to be there. You had to be there. It was a geography joke. And then Michael sees the clock and does exactly what they hope for. He's like, well, let's all go home. I had a teeny tiny catch on Pam's desk at one minute 33 seconds when we're all laughing. I noticed, and I had forgotten this, that she has a Pratt mug on her desk that is what is holding all of her pens and pencils. And then she has her pink mug that she's drinking out of. But I spotted that Pratt mug.
但你必须在现场。你必须在现场。这是一个地理笑话。然后迈克尔看到了时钟，做出了他们所希望的完全一样的反应。他就像，好吧，我们都回家吧。我在一分33秒时对帕姆的桌子有一个微小的发现，当时我们都在笑。我注意到，我把这个给忘了，她的桌子上有一个普拉特（Pratt）马克杯，里面插着她所有的钢笔和铅笔。然后她有她正在喝的粉红色马克杯。但我发现了那个普拉特马克杯。
Aw. That's a great detail from our set decoration crew. Well, I love that. I was way in the corner back by Stanley's file cabinet, and that was just trying to get me in the shot. Ken Quapas had me come out from accounting. Once again, I'm standing. And that's how we could all be there. Well, now we have our super short opening credits. They are like 10 seconds. Jen Salada did an interview with Office Talley, and she said they cut the credits down to get more time for the episode. She mentioned that they had gone back and forth about maybe making this episode an hour,
啊。那是我们的布景装饰团队的一个极好的细节。好吧，我喜欢那个。我当时在斯坦利文件柜后面的那个角落里，那只是为了把我拍进镜头里。肯·卡皮斯让我从会计部出来。又一次，我站着。这就是我们都能在那里的原因。好吧，现在我们有了超级短的片头字幕。它们大约只有10秒钟。珍·萨拉达接受了Office Tally的采访，她说他们把字幕剪短了，以便为这一集腾出更多时间。她提到他们曾反复讨论过是否把这一集做成一个小时，
But she said they didn't feel like they needed it. There were other season finales like The Job or Goodbye Toby, where they had like tons of plot points to wrap up and huge moves they were going to make. But in this episode, she said they didn't have that much. They just had kind of the one big move with Jim and Pam and a little bit of a move for Michael and Holly. And then the rest of us just little nods to our storylines. Yeah. But she said they did need to steal that little bit of time from the credits.
但她说他们觉得没那个必要。还有其他的季终集，比如《工作》或《告别托比》，在那些集里他们有大量的剧情点需要收尾，还有重大的举动要做出。但在这一集中，她说他们没有那么多。他们只有吉姆和帕姆的一个大动作，还有迈克尔和霍莉的一点小动作。然后我们其余的人都只是对我们剧情线的一点小暗示。对。但她说他们确实需要从字幕中偷走那一点点时间。
The day has arrived. It is the Dunder Mifflin Company Picnic. Here's a breakdown of all the different branches and their t-shirts. Oh, thank you Dunderpedia. I started making notes and then I saw you had it. So I'm going to read what you have. Corporate, black t-shirts, Akron, yellow, Albany light blue, Buffalo orange, Nashua green, Rochester dark purple, Scranton red, and Utica dark blue. Lady, I'm calling this episode the Plain Hats Club. Oh, I can't wait to hear this because I have some lingo I made up for this episode as well. Everyone in this episode is wearing a plain hat. And that is because if you wear a logo anywhere on your shirt or your hat, the production has to get it cleared with that company first. So I have a breakdown of everyone's plain hat.
这一天终于到来了。这就是邓德米夫林公司野餐。这里是所有不同分公司及其T恤的解析。哦，谢谢你，Dunderpedia。我开始做笔记，然后我看到你有了。所以我打算读一下你手头有的。总部，黑色T恤，阿克伦，黄色，奥尔巴尼浅蓝色，布法罗橙色，纳舒厄绿色，罗切斯特深紫色，斯克兰顿红色，尤蒂卡深蓝色。女士，我把这一集叫做“素净帽子俱乐部”。哦，我等不及要听这个了，因为我为这一集也编造了一些行话。这一集里的每个人都戴着一顶素净的帽子。
Like the plain baseball hats? Yes. Jim is wearing a plain black baseball. baseball hat. Pam has a white visor. Dwight has a tan fishing hat, which I googled and I learned is called a bucket hat. Kevin is also wearing a tan bucket hat. Angela has a floppy sun hat. Andy has a tan Panama hat. Aaron has a sort of light purple baseball hat. Creed has a light tan baseball hat. Ryan has a white visor. Stanley has a straw sun hat. Phyllis has a straw sun hat. Phyllis has a No hat while she's playing volleyball, but she has a Straw Sun hat on the sidelines. Meredith has no hat. Oscar has no hat. Charles Minor has a black Nike visor. How do we get away with that? I don't know. Because it's Idris and we're just like let Idris do what he wants to do. We're just glad to have you back. I don't know. Toby also has a yellow baseball hat with a logo. It has little trees, but I couldn't read what it was.
就像那些普通的棒球帽？是的。吉姆戴着一顶普通的黑色棒球帽。帕姆戴着一个白色的遮阳帽。德怀特戴着一顶棕色的渔夫帽，我用谷歌查了一下，了解到它叫水桶帽。凯文也戴着一顶棕色的水桶帽。安吉拉戴着一顶宽檐遮阳帽。安迪戴着一顶棕色的巴拿马草帽。艾伦戴着一顶有点浅紫色的棒球帽。克里德戴着一顶浅棕色的棒球帽。瑞安戴着一个白色的遮阳帽。斯坦利戴着一顶草编遮阳帽。菲利斯戴着一顶草编遮阳帽。菲利斯在打排球时没戴帽子，但她在场边戴了一顶草编遮阳帽。梅雷迪思没有帽子。奥斯卡没有帽子。查尔斯·迈纳戴着一顶黑色的耐克遮阳帽。我们是怎么逃过这一劫的？我不知道。因为他是伊德里斯，我们就像是让伊德里斯做他想做的事。我们只是很高兴你回来。我不知道。托比也戴着一顶带有标志的黄色棒球帽。上面有小树，但我看不清那是什么。
Well, you know, part of the hat strategy was because it got so hot during the day. We needed it. We needed it when we were playing volleyball as well to kind of create a shade on our faces so that you could see our expressions. So we weren't completely blown out by the sun, also for sun protection. But you might notice that Michael and Holly do not wear hats. They are mostly in their cutesy little, like, love nest shady area. Yeah, exactly. Well, Jenna, I also did a little bit of tracking. I want you to know that I feel like this episode really brings out some of our character's other traits. Oh.
好吧，你知道，帽子战略的一部分是因为那天太热了。我们需要它。我们在打排球时也需要它来在脸部制造阴影，这样你就能看到我们的表情。这样我们才不会被太阳完全烤焦，也是为了防晒。但你可能会注意到迈克尔和霍莉没有戴帽子。他们大多在他们可爱的、像爱巢一样的阴凉区里。是的，完全是。好吧，珍娜，我也做了一点追踪。我想让你知道，我觉得这一集真的展现了我们某些角色的一些其他特质。哦。
I made a list. We have sporty Pam. Mm-hmm. Saucy Jim. Petty Charles. Trash-talking Andy. Snarky Michael. And my most favorite Vacation Stanley.
我列了个单子。我们有运动型帕姆。嗯哼。调情吉姆。小心眼的查尔斯。喷垃圾话的安迪。刻薄的迈克尔。还有我最喜欢的度假斯坦利。
I love Vacation Stanley. So the picnic starts with Pam and Jim. they're walking up and they share a little bit about what last year's softball company picnic was like. Jim had that spider in his mitt, but that's not what Pam is talking about. She's talking about the guy who grabbed her boobs to keep his balance. Uh-huh. And then Pam points at her chest and says, yeah, you don't grab these for balance. And Jim goes, well, and this is saucy Jim.
我喜欢度假斯坦利。所以野餐从帕姆和吉姆开始。他们走过来，分享了一点去年垒球公司野餐是什么样子的。吉姆的手套里有那只蜘蛛，但这并不是帕姆在谈论的。她在谈论那个为了保持平衡而抓她胸部的家伙。嗯哼。然后帕姆指着自己的胸部说，是的，你抓这些可不是为了平衡。吉姆说，嗯，这就是调情吉姆。
Well, next up, Dwight arrives with. his friend, Rolf. His best friend. Who they met at a shoe store when Dwight overheard Rolf asking for a shoe that would increase his speed but not leave any tracks. These two are made for each other.
We had a fan question from David H. in Pennsylvania. Who played Dwight's friend? Was he somehow related to the show already? Guys, Rolf was played by the amazing James Urbaniac. And get this, Ange. What?
He auditioned and was called back for the role of Dwight. Well, that makes perfect sense to me. Doesn't it? He and Ray knew each other from their New York theater days. And after Rain read this script, he called James and gave him a heads up. And he told Greg, you need to bring in James Urbaneiac for this. Well, they knew him because they had auditioned him.
So he went into see Allison Jones. He read for the role and he got the part. Ken talked a little bit in the DVD commentary about just how perfectly cast James was and that for a guest star to come in on such a big episode, James just fit in so seamlessly you would have never known he had never been on the show before. That is just how organic his performance was and that he just crushed it. Well, he's one of those guys who's been a working actor for a very, very long time. And I feel like he's one of those people where you recognize him immediately from his body of work. He's a pro. We got this interesting letter from Jana M in Westport County, Mayo, Ireland.
Oh, wow. We have letters from everywhere. This is so exciting to me. You know, we added a feature on the website where you can say where you're writing from. I love that. I know, me too, because it's really fun to see how international the show is. I know. Well, when we get mail here to Earwolf that I open, I can always see where people are from. But before in emails, we weren't always sure. Here is what Jana said. Fun fact, James Urbaniac, the actor who played Dwight's best friend Rolfe, whom he met in a shoe store, also played a shoe store. Also played a shoe. store employee with a foot fetish on sex in the city. What is it about James Urbaniac and shoe stores?
That's really funny. I think that's fun. And now Christine B. from Mississippi asked this. I've heard that Rolf was introduced because Moes was busy on Parks and Rec. Is that true? Oh, savvy question. It is true. You guys originally Moes was supposed to come to the picnic with Dwight. And they called up Mike Scher, who was now running Parks and Rec. And the week we shot Company Picnic, he was directing an episode of Parks and Rec as well as running the show. And he was like, you guys, I can't do it. And I guess they begged him, like, Jen and Paul. They were like, please, you have to come be Mo's.
And he's like, you guys, I can't do it. I am running a whole other show now. Yes. And then, you know, we're going to have Mike on the show. I can't wait. And he's going to tell us a little bit about how he also truly hated playing Moes. Hated it. Hated it.
So I think he was like really happy that he had a good excuse to not be out in this field in his wool clothes for four days. It also made sense to me that Dwight wouldn't have brought Moes to the company picnic. And I love this twist that he's got this best friend. Yeah. You know, there's a deleted talking head that made me laugh. but also sad where Michael says he usually brings the guy from his condo with him. But this year he came by himself. The guy from his condo.
Yeah. Well, Rolf is going to appear in four episodes of The Office. This was his first. We loved you, James. He was really fun to work with. So fun. Now enters Holly. Oh, and Michael, Caesar, and Kevin's like, there's Holly.
And Michael's like, oh, you know, we're just friends. There's a whole awkward greeting between Holly and her boyfriend, AJ, with Michael. And Jenna, this begins, snarky Michael. Steve does this thing as Michael I love so much where he lets his hatred for someone just barely poke out. So he says, hey, I could get you guys some lemonade. Holly says, lemonade sounds great. Michael goes, okay, AJ says, I'd love an iced tea, actually. And Michael goes, you can go to hell.
Just kidding. Just kidding. He'll get him the best iced tea in the world. Yeah. First of all, Rob Heubel is back as AJ. Uh-huh. And he's so good. He's being so nice to Michael.
I know. And you're like, the whole episode. The whole episode. And you're like, oh, my gosh, this guy must really love Holly to be that patient with Michael. I want to point out in this scene that Kevin is having a beer. Yes. Holly asks for a lemonade. AJ wants an iced tea.
According to a big banner in the back. background. You can really see it over Michael's shoulder in his upcoming talking head. There is a breakdown of everything the Dunder Mifflin Company picnic is serving. Oh. Food was hamburgers, turkey burgers, hot dogs, corn on the cob, salads. Listen to the beverage list. Pina colada. Charles drinks one of those. My Thai. Stanley drinks one of those. Hurricane. Oh, wow. Tequila sunrise. Dang. Beer. Wine, so does water. No iced tea. No lemonade.
Lots of booze. Lots of booze. You know, Michael has a talking head where he says, I lied to Kevin. Holly and I could never just be friends. And he wrote a whole list of bullet points why they should be together on like a receipt, on some kind of receipt.
He didn't use a proper piece of paper. No. And he's trying to read it. And he can't really make out what he wrote. He said, And then he tries to justify it by being like, I think, okay, yeah, I think it's because when we have soup. Mm-hmm. And then he's like, no, no. Soulmates. Well, we had a fan question from Tracy C. and Georgia, who said this, I have been holding on to this fast fact for so long.
Please include it in this episode. What is it? Mindy describes her and BJ's relationship as soup snakes because she, She loves the scene where Michael misreads his own handwriting, and instead of saying that he and Holly are soulmates, he says they are soup snakes. You guys, this is true. In Mindy's book, Why Not Me? Here's what it says, quote, we're soup snakes. BJ and I are soup snakes.
And then she added, soulmates is what you aim for, but soup snakes is what you get sometimes. Aw. Is that so sweet? Yeah. They are soup snakes. They are soup snakes. Pam and Jim are going to say hi to Charles, who right out of the gate says, nice day, huh? Jim says, yeah. Charles says, must be nice to get a rest from all your rest and walks away. I call this petty Charles. I want you to know Charles was way more snarky in this episode, but a lot of it got deleted. Oh, no. Yeah. Well, Jenny Tan said that when she was kind of going around talking to all the actors, she said both Rob Hewbel and. Adris talked to her about what it was like to have fans hate on them. Oh, really? Yes, because Charles was always mean to Jim. But I have to say, lady, he is not wrong on his read of Jim. Like, Jim is very charming, but he, I mean, he slacks off. He is a slacker. He gets his work done ultimately,
but he could be more ambitious with his time. Well, yeah, that comes for him later in life. He will become more ambitious in later seasons. All right, lady, it is time to play volleyball. Yeah. Dwight is assigning positions to the Scranton team. Andy is like Bromigo, put Aaron next to me. All of Andy's ridiculous things, Bromigo is pretty great. Well, guess what? The Scranton team is not doing well. Aaron misses the ball. Andy starts screaming at her, Are you blind? And then he catches himself and he redirects. the question in earnest to the man on the other side of the net wearing sunglasses, he's like, no, I'm really, are you blind? Guess what? Sunglasses man was played by our very own editor,
Dave Rogers. Yeah. But the game continues. Kevin is not great. Phyllis sits down in the middle of the game. Ryan is on his cell phone. Yeah. And now it's time for Pam to serve. And Dwight is like condescending. He's like, are you left-handed or are you right-handed? Think about how you hold the phone. And Pam's like, you know what, Dwight, back off. Mm-hmm. I got it. This is sporty Pam.
Oh, she spikes that serve. She does. And then she's like, maybe I played a little in junior high and in high school, maybe a little in college. And went to volleyball camp most and you do this really cute thing. Do you know where you go, Samas? Well, this created a fan mail flurry. lady. It did? Oh, yes. You know, Rose G from Colorado sums up all the letters nicely by saying in season four, Pam says that she used PMS as an excuse to get out of volleyball gym class. But here, Pam is real good at volleyball.
What is up with this plot inconsistency? Now, we did discuss this when we broke down job fair. You had your theory. Yes, there was a fan theory that Pam wanted out of the non-competitive gym class volleyball. This is a very kind theory. This is like, I mean, this is a very kind, kind. Like, let's just make any excuse. Well, Jen Salata did an interview for Office Talley, and she admitted they just forgot about that line when they wrote this. Of course they did. They didn't strategically plot out like, you know what? Pam was so competitive.
She didn't want to do PE volleyball. Right. I still like that theory. I know, I know. Pam continues to dominate. She wins the game for her team, advances them to the next round. because I am just that good. Yeah.
Well, I have a kid catch. What's the kid catch? So my kids rewatched this episode with me. They could not get over at seven minutes, 43 seconds. There is a full-on face body plant. This must have been someone with special business as volleyball. Because when Pam serves, you've got to look at the person who misses the ball. They throw themselves.
They fly through the air. and they land in one clump face down. I was like, is this a stunt person? I mean, Jenna, I have to show it to you. I'm going to put it in stories. This is how this person lands. Not even break their fall with their arms. I know.
That is intense. Well, I have a tidbit to share about that. Okay. But first, let me do some fan questions. Peyton H from Vermont said, Jenna, I know there was a stunt double for you in some of your volleyball scenes, but my question is, how much was you
and how much was the stunt double. And Megan B from Jerome Idaho said, have you played much volleyball in real life? All right. I'm going to break down all the volleyball. I love all these questions, you guys. I love them because you know I know the answer to some of them and others I'm intrigued.
I have played a lot of volleyball. You don't say. I have. When? In like grade school? Your youth? High school. Okay.
My youth at the beach. I know how to play. volleyball. And I have a really great underhand serve. So do I. Very consistent. Nothing fancy, but we'll always get in. Same. They didn't want that for Pam. I offered to do it. They weren't interested. They wanted overhand serve. Because you know in varsity high school, you have to serve overhand. I did not know that. I did not play varsity. I know this because my daughter's playing volleyball. She is. In junior high, she can still do underhand, but they're wanting them already to do overhand. Well, here was the problem. I have a shoulder injury. I have tendinitis in my right shoulder and it's really bad. And I have a sort of like lack of range of motion. And doing that overhead swoopy motion, it's even a little sore. I'm doing it now. It's even a little bit sore if I'm holding nothing in my hand or if I'm not hitting a volleyball.
What? Why are you laughing? Why is so funny? I just, what? I was just going to say, an alias. Oh, my God. You're still tracking why I can't be on alias? I will for the rest of my life. How can you swing on a rope and, like, do a cartwheel and, like, throw a grenade or whatever she did? I mean, you're making a good point. Okay, go on. I haven't thought about that.
You know, they didn't ask me. me in my audition, how my overhand range of motion was. Well, that might have rolled it out. They shouldn't have even auditioned me for that role. There's no way I could have swung on a rope. All right, well, listen, they had to get me a stunt double. Her name was Nancy McCrum. And Randy was kind enough to send me her photo, which will post in the Office Lady Pod
stories. And he sent me her resume. On her resume, it shows her height and her weight, which I just want to say. I can't believe I used to weigh that. Oh, because they matched her height and weight to you? Yes. When they find you a body double or a stunt double, they have to match the person's height, the weight, the general hair color, or they'll put a wig on the person or color that person's
hair. But it's more than that because I was on this one movie and they had to get a body double for me. And the woman showed up and she was my height and weight. But her like weight distribution was totally different from mine. So walking. She didn't look like me. She didn't look like you. This happened to me, Jenna.
I did a movie called Struck by Lightning, and there was this long tracking dolly scene that started in a room and ended up on the sofa that I was sitting on. Okay. And they had a body double for me for all the lighting setup because it was going to take a really long time to get this set up. So after an hour of them setting this all up, using the body double, it's time for me to report on set. we do this long, intricate tracking shot. The camera's coming down, this long track, lands on me on the sofa, and it cuts part of my head off. Well, what they found out was she was my exact height. They immediately called for her because the director of photography had set up all this time for the shot. And he said, are you 5-1? And she said, yes. And she came and stood next to me. We were the same height. And then he said,
sit side by side. We sat side by side. I had a longer torso than she did. Yes. This is a what I'm saying. So they had to like measure her. Like did we have the same waist? The circumference of your thigh, like all of that. And Nancy McCrum was just an exact body double for me. Well, I could never tell that there was a body double there. So they did a great job. Well, here's what I did. She was also very good at volleyball. And she taught me how to do the motion, how to jump up, how to serve it and all of that. And I did a whole, whole bunch of takes and we used a CGI ball. So that you didn't have to actually make the contact. Yeah. Randy reminded me that the very first time I tried to do it by making contact with the ball and I like winced in pain. And he was like, no, no, no more ball. We're never having her
do that again. Because like we said, he was so good at taking care of us. He was like, we're going to do a CGI ball. But he said while the serving and putting in a fake ball was not difficult. It was really difficult to have people dive for a fake ball. Yes. So that person that is diving in that video you just showed me is diving at nothing. Well, that might... That commitment. That might make sense a little bit. On the DVD commentary, Ken was very complimentary in saying that Jenna, you did great fakey arm motion. Yeah, well, I have to give credit to Nancy because she was such a good teacher. We became a little chummy on this episode. And they did shoot with her a little bit from behind with a real ball. And that was really helpful for the people on the other side, because
then they were diving for a real ball, and they used some of those shots. But I'm not sure if they ever ended up using any of her serves. I think they were mostly my faky serves that made it in. But I do want to say one more thing, which is that over on officetellee.com, Jenny Tan took a bunch of amazing photos of me serving with no ball. Oh, really? And they're really cool. And I grabbed them so that we can put them up on Office Ladies' Pod. Your story about Nancy, Jenna, just reminded me of an amazing run-in I just had four years. Steve had a body double named Eric Sulkie. And Jenna, Josh and I were in the wine country for our anniversary. And I hear Angela and I turn around. And there is Eric and his wife. No way. He is still working.
with Steve. It's been like 16 years they've been working together. They're working together on a movie right now. Look at that. Oh my gosh. Yes, I remember him. I know. He was so lovely. And I said, Eric, it's so crazy to see you outside of a suit because he was just in casual clothes. Yeah. But sometimes when Steve needed out for, you know, something they had to get him to a talk show or whatever, Eric and a suit would sit in the office there in the background in Michael Scott's office. You could catch his shoulder or the side of him. And they are still working together now, 16 years. I love that.
Me too. Well, listen, ladies, should we take a little break? And then when we come back, we will talk about Michael and Holly and what they're up to. Yeah. I think we need to come back and talk about some chair pants. Great. We're back. And also, Snarky Michael is with us.
He gets a big piece of news here. He really does. Bless his heart. They tell him that they're designing a house. And he says, for who? And AJ says, for us. And then Michael says, well, wow, I'm designing a chair. It's part of your pants.
You sit down. You're supported. Holly lights up. She's like, I remember your chair pants idea. And AJ's like, I like that. Put me down for a pair. I'm a size 34 waist. Here comes snarky, Michael. He can't take it anymore. He says, all right, fatty, I will do it. You know what? We should actually rehearse. He wants to get Holly away from AJ. And AJ says, you guys are really going to do this? And Michael says, you bet you're fat ass we are. Because he can't contain, like how much he's freaking out that this guy has just swooped in and is taking the love of his life.
You sit down. You're supported. Holly lights up. She's like, I remember your chair pants idea. And AJ's like, I like that. Put me down for a pair. I'm a size 34 waist. Here comes snarky, Michael. He can't take it anymore. He says, all right, fatty, I will do it. You know what? We should actually rehearse. He wants to get Holly away from AJ. And AJ says, you guys are really going to do this? And Michael says, you bet your'e fat ass we are. Because he can't contain, like how much he's freaking out that this guy has just swooped in and is taking the love of his life.
To build a house. To build a house. To build a home. To become a family. Oh. Oh. Well, we have this really sweet talking head where Michael and Holly together explain that David Wallace has authorized them to perform a presentation on the history of Dunder Nifflin.
Again, David Wallace, what are you thinking? I don't know. Well, Holly and Michael are going to find a nice little quiet place to rehearse. He brought her chocolate-covered strawberries. When I rewatch this with my kids, they were like, wow, because I think they associate those with Valentine's. When you go to the grocery store, there's always a big chocolate-covered strawberry display for Valentine's. It's a very romantic gift. It is.
What snacks do you bring to a picnic? You bring like potato chips, some salsa, chocolate-covered strawberries. By the way, I love that your picnic items are potato chips and salsa. I have never brought potato chips and salsa. You don't like chips and salsa? But don't you eat corn chips or like... Tortilla chips. Okay, I'm sorry.
But also, I've never brought salsa to like a picnic blanket. It's so messy. Like I... The chips, yeah. But like, I don't bring dips to a picnic. I don't think dip when I think picnic. Lady, lady, when my husband first came home with me to meet my family, my mom said to him, we're dippers and chippers.
Okay. We always have some kind of dip and something like a chip to eat it with. Even on your picnics. Most definitely on a picnic. Okay. It just seems like a mess waiting to happen. Give me all the dips. All right.
And, you know, bring some paper towels. Well, I have something crazy to share about this location where they shot these Michael and Holly scenes. The tree, the little shady tree? Yes. Randy said that this shaded location was the most troublesome of the whole. shoot. Why? He said, first off, they really wanted a romantic private area where these two could sneak off to, but they still needed to feel the picnic in the background. And it was really hard to find the right spot. The one that they settled on drove Randall crazy. I guess there were
these overhanging trees, and then there was like a muddy creek where his lighting equipment needed to go. And we usually shot our show with just two cameras. But for this, they had to add a third camera. And it's because they just couldn't cover it with these over the shoulders. They looked good, but they really wanted a two shot of them from the front. But listen to this, and I barely understand how they did it. Okay. It was so tight in this area that the only way that they could do it was they had to set up a mirror
and they shot the camera into the mirror, and then in order to make it match the over-the-shoulder shots, they reversed them in post. Because when they shot in the mirror, they were on the wrong sides. It was this special mirror called like an optically correct mirror. I barely understand this, but it was a huge ordeal. Well, it sounds like a huge ordeal.
I'm also very curious, could Steve and Amy see their reflections as they did the scene because that would be weird. I wouldn't, I don't want to watch myself because then I'd be like, what are you doing with your face, lady? What is that expression? I would be so distracted. Yeah. So I don't know.
My question was like, did they just have this mirror on standby? Like, is that part of their kit? They have an optically correct mirror in your camera kit. I feel like that's a special order, lady. It sounds like a special order, but it also sounds like they kind of had to figure this out on the fly, but I don't know. Maybe it was part of their planning scout. Get that mirror.
case we need it and get a third camera. You would have never known it by watching that scene, though. It was so beautiful and effortless. I would have never known there was a mirror or a third camera. There's this great, great moment between Holly and Michael is they're brainstorming their ideas, right? Yeah, they're going to do this skit, but this is the first time they've met to figure out the skit that's going to be going up soon. And Michael has no script. He just wants to wing it. So they start spitballing like movie spoofs, right, to get out this information about how Robert Dunder and Robert Mifflin met. Only part of it was scripted, Jenna. Stephen Amy just improvised and Ken said they love the improv. They just let the camera keep going and going. Really? Yes. Here's
how the scene started as written. Holly's like, what about back to the future? Yeah. That was scripted. The rest of this part was not. Ready? What? Yeah. Yeah. And. And, How about back to the future? Steve improvises, could we get a DeLorean? So funny. Amy improvises Jaws. They swim in the ocean and they terrorize the whole community. And then at the same time, like this sort of group mind, they both start going,
Dunder, Dunder, Dunder, Dunder, Dunder, that's all improvised. And then they both start cracking up at nine minutes, 44 seconds, go to that time code. The two of them are laughing. And I think it's because they're just cracking up. Like, they're just having a good time. Wow. I think they're both genuinely tickled that they came up with the dunder dunder in the moment. It's brilliant.
It's brilliant. And then they go back on script at the very end when Holly's like, we haven't found our great idea yet. And Michael says, but we're circling it. Wow. Mm-hmm. Wow. That was an improv in the middle of a scene. Yeah.
Usually our improvs happened at the end. Yeah. And Ken and Paul and Jen said that the two of them were just magic together. You just see it. You really do. Ladies, should we go back to the volleyball game? It's getting heated. Pam scores another point.
They're going to move on to the finals. Phyllis is like over it. Yeah, she twists her ankle. And then trots over to Bob Vance. Yeah, she has no problem running over. And then there's classic Vacation Stanley where he's like, you just had to be part of the group. And he's got his cocktail and his hat. I'm telling you, this is setting up Florida Stanley.
Oh, you're so right about that. Well, now we need a replacement for Phyllis, and Rolf is going to call up Meredith, even though Angela volunteers. Rolf is so intense. Yeah, Rolf says he didn't hear Angela volunteer because he doesn't hear cheaters, tramps, or women who break my friend's heart. Ooh. And then there's this look between Dwight and Angela.
I have two little tidbits to share about this scene. Number one. Okay, so you know the part where I bump the ball? Yeah. Okay, that was not a CGI ball. That was me. That was real. And then when Phyllis is running to the sidelines, I spotted a man in a Yankees baseball hat. We took all of the trouble to put the whole cast in plain hats. And then they just let a guy sit in the front row with a Yankees hat on? What is that? What is that? It's a lot of people. Someone's going to fall through the crows. You know, what they would usually do if someone showed up with a hat or something with a logo on it, they would have tape in different colors and they would just tape over it. Oh, yeah. Someone did not tape over Yankees guy. Or maybe they did and he ripped it off. Scandalous.
Oh, my gosh. We just had a Dunder moment. We did. We had a group mind Dunder Dunder Dunder on Scandalous. Well, Jim is going to score a point and some trash talking starts. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. David Wallace says, we're still going to crush you, though.
Charles is like, yeah, we are. Ralph comes out of nowhere. Oh, my gosh. We could not get through this. Yes, we were all cracking up. He said, you suckers are going down. They're going to wipe their asses with your serves and piss all over your faces. Every time he said piss all over your faces, we would lose it.
Yeah. And Rain is Dwight had to be like, whoa, whoa, whoa, come on, come on. But we kept laughing. Well, now we're going to go to this little. tidbit, the HR folks. And I love it so much, lady. John Hartman is back as corporate HR Kendall. Toby is wearing his logo hat. And they are discussing the HR convention last year. I could have watched the two of them talk for 20 minutes. Ken shared that Greg had this idea that David Wallace would hate Kendall the same way Michael
hates Toby. My gosh, it's so funny. Well, listen. one more point, and Scranton is going to move on to play corporate, and Jim makes it. I mean, Dwight hugs Jim. Yeah. They're so excited. I know. Oscar's like settle down, guys. Relax, fellas. Jenna, Scranton was so good. Is that your memory that you guys were good at playing volleyball? I guess that's my memory. That Scranton, Dundra Mifflin was good. That we were good. That's your memory. Yeah. Like, are you saying in real life? Yeah. Like, I, like, I, fictionally and in real life. Yeah. Why? Because... Why are you smiling? Because... I feel like this is a trap.
Because that is not how Ken, Jen, or Paul remembered it. And Ken talked about a lot of the ways the volleyball scenes were logistically difficult. And one of them was because you guys were all terrible. And they all three talk about it on the DVD commentary. Can we hear that? Volleyball is hard to direct, especially with people who don't have a clue on a flight. Oh my God, I couldn't believe it. They were terrible, I will say. Corporate, every other team that was playing against them, so much better. I don't know why our people were not going to volleyball players. I wasn't editing. Paul and I were alternating days on the set, and Paul was like, it's going really well, but our team is terrible.
I don't know what to do. And I was like, well, maybe the other teams could be made to be worse. I know there was one point where I said, I think Scranton was playing Nashua, maybe Utica. And I just said, let's just play for a while. Let's just play some volleyball as we get warmed up. And Utica killed us. And I can tell looking at our cast, they all look so sad. This is a terrible idea.
Let's just go back to the scene. Oh, my gosh. You guys were the worst. The worst group there. Hey, to be fair, the other teams were filled with special business actors. Okay? So after I listened to the DVD commentary, I thought, oh, I've got to watch Scranton and Utica play. Ken said that Utica crushed you guys.
So I went back and watched the episode, and I never saw you guys play Utica. It's in the deleted scenes. Oh, wow. Yeah, and it features some major trash-talking Andy. Send it back. Yeah, send that ball back. Don't mess with Squantone. No!
Uh-huh. Utica, more like you sucks to cuff. Who sucks toka? You sucks toka. Who sucks toka? Who sucks toka? You suckstica. Oh, ow.
嗯哼。尤蒂卡，听起来更像你们真烂。谁烂？你们烂。谁烂？谁烂？你们真烂。哦，哎哟。
Sorry. Jim comes up to Andy and Dwight, and he's, like, pinching their arms so they stop. But, yeah, Andy starts this whole chant about you sucks toka. Oh, my gosh. But in reality, they were crushing us. Yeah. Oh, I love that. Don't miss with Scranton.
抱歉。吉姆走到安迪和德怀特面前，掐住他们的胳膊让他们停下。不过，是的，安迪开始带头喊口号，说你们真烂。哦，天哪。但实际上，他们把我们打得落花流水。是的。哦，我太喜欢这个了。别跟斯克兰顿过不去。
That made me laugh so hard. It's time for Michael and Holly's presentation. Oh, gosh. This is when David says I have not seen this. He announces that they're going to sing a song. And they're like, no, no, it's a sketch. No, it's a sketch. Like, David, you should already be worried.
这让我笑得前仰后合。轮到迈克尔和霍莉的演讲了。哦，天哪。这就是戴维说他还没看过这个的时候。他宣布他们要唱首歌。然后他们说，不，不，这是个小品。不，是个小品。就像是，戴维，你现在就该担心了。
Yeah. And then they say, introducing Slumdunder Miflunair. So Slumdog Millionaire was a hit movie that came out in 2008. according to IMDB, and this is a very brief synopsis, this is what it says. A Mumbai teenager reflects on his life after being accused of cheating on the Indian version of Who Wants to Be a Millionaire? Well, I saw this movie. It was fantastic. Oh, it's so good.
对。然后他们说，隆重推出《贫民窟的米夫林富翁》。所以《贫民窟的百万富翁》是2008年上映的一部大热电影。根据IMDB的资料，这是一个非常简短的梗概，内容如下：一个孟买少年在被指控在印度版《谁想成为百万富翁？》中作弊后，反思了自己的生活。嗯，我看过这部电影。太棒了。哦，太棒了。
It's so good. Everyone was talking about it. Yes, it was huge, just a great film. It won a gazillion of awards, including the Academy Award for Best Picture in 2009. But of all the movies to parody, to tell the story of Robert Dunder and Robert Mifflin coming together, no one knows what they're doing. Well, they're also going to get some facts wrong. Van Catch from Casey K in Orlando, Florida. In Michael and Holly's sketch, they say that Dunder and Mifflin met in college.
太棒了。每个人都在谈论它。是的，太火了，真是一部伟大的电影。它获得了无数奖项，包括2009年奥斯卡最佳影片奖。但在所有用来恶搞、讲述罗伯特·邓德和罗伯特·米夫林走到一起的故事的电影中，没有人知道他们在做什么。嗯，他们还会弄错一些事实。来自佛罗里达州奥兰多凯西K的粉丝留言。在迈克尔和霍莉的小品中，他们说邓德和米夫林是在大学里相遇的。
At Dartmouth, which incidentally is where Mindy went. But in Dunder Mifflin Infinity, Robert Mifflin said he knew Dunder through the road. club. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. So I caught it too. Yeah. Ken shared that they really just drove home with the crowd watching to please not react in any way.
在达特茅斯，顺便说一句，这也是明迪去的地方。但在《邓德米夫林无限公司》中，罗伯特·米夫林说他通过赛艇俱乐部认识了邓德。嗯哼。嗯哼。所以我当时也注意到了。是的。肯分享说，他们实际上只是在观众注视下开车回家，祈求大家千万不要做出任何反应。
Even the children don't crack a smile, nothing. Mm-hmm. And Ken was so happy with how the scene turned out because everyone really just looks at them so dead pan. And Ken said that Steve and Amy pulled him aside after the first take. And they were like, this feels really uncomfortable. So it's like so awkward. Amy was like, I'm rattled by it.
甚至连孩子们都不露一丝笑容，什么都没有。嗯哼。肯对这个场景的呈现效果非常满意，因为每个人看着他们的表情都面无表情。肯说史蒂夫和艾米在拍完第一条后把拉到一边。他们说，这感觉真的很不舒服。所以气氛太尴尬了。艾米说，我被它搞得心神不宁。
Because it truly felt like they were bombing on stage in front of everyone. Well, I guess this sketch took like hours to shoot. And in addition to being told not to laugh, the extras were not allowed to move from their spots for continuity reasons. So we would bring waters around and things like that. But they had to stay right there. And Jenny Tan had this tidbit in her breakdown from her visit. Andy Buckley, who plays David Wallace, would get on the little stage during the breaks, and he would entertain the crowd with stories and jokes.
因为这感觉真像是他们在所有人面前演砸了。嗯，我猜这个小品拍了好几个小时。除了被告知不准笑之外，出于连戏的原因，群演们也不允许离开他们的位置。所以我们会送水过去之类的。但他们必须待在原地。詹妮·坦在她的片场探班记录里有这样一个细节：饰演戴维·وال斯（Wallace）的安迪·巴克利会在休息时走上小舞台，用故事和笑话来逗乐观众。
She said he even sang a song. Oh my gosh. But he was like the entertainment. And she said it was just like the sweetest, most thoughtful thing. And you know what? That is Andy Buckley right there. Yeah. I was like, of course he did that.
她说他甚至还唱了首歌。哦，天哪。但他就像个娱乐担当。并且她说这简直是最甜蜜、最贴心的举动。你知道吗？那正是安迪·巴克利的作风。是的。当时我想，他当然会这么做。
course. That is so sweet. Yeah. Well, the only person that's enjoying this is Stanley. We have some classic vacation Stanley when he has his cocktail and he says, I usually don't enjoy the theater, but this is delightful. I think he's had a few cocktails by this point. I guess he has. There's a lot of booze being offered at this event. Now Michael and Holly are going to do something. They're going to announce that the buffalo branch is closing and then they take a bow. This is a news to the Buffalo Branch. They are ticked off. Well, there are two especially very angry Buffalo Branch employees. They were played by Brian Stack and Marla Garland. Brian Stack was a writer on Conan, and I've known Marla for years. She is just delightful. Well, also seated in the front row,
当然。太贴心了。好吧，唯一享受这一切的人是斯坦利。我们看到了一些经典的度假斯坦利，当时他拿着鸡尾酒说：我通常不喜欢看戏，但这太令人愉快了。我想他此时已经喝了几杯鸡尾酒了。我猜是的。这次活动提供了大量的酒。现在迈克尔和霍莉要做点事情了。他们要宣布布法罗分公司要关闭，然后他们鞠躬致意。这对布法罗分公司来说是个大新闻。他们气炸了。好吧，有两个特别生气的布法罗分公司员工。他们由布라이언·斯塔克（Brian Stack）和玛拉·加兰（Marla Garland）饰演。布莱恩·斯塔克是柯南秀的编剧，我认识玛拉很多年了。她非常讨人喜欢。好吧，同样坐在第一排的还有——
who's very upset about this branch closing, is Jenny Tan. Yes. And she revealed that she was in the front row with a real-life husband and wife couple, Dan and Aaron, who were booked together to play extras on this episode. They gave them two fake babies. And it's really great. You can see Dan sitting next to Jenny. And when Brian Stack, as the angry Buffalo man, is yelling, he's shushing his baby. He's like, shh, shh, shh, shh. Don't let the angry man upset you, baby. Yes, exactly. Exactly, exactly. David Wallace is furious. This is not how he wanted the buffalo branch to find out. No, he says one little boy just asked him if Daddy will have his job at Christmas. And Michael's like, well, he's just thinking about his own gifts. Not helping Michael. The Scranton group huddles up. They're over by the picnic tables. And Meredith is like, I think we should forfeit the game out of respect. And Dwight says people need volleyball now more than ever. Oscar,
对这家分公司关闭感到非常生气的，是詹妮·坦。是的。她透露自己坐在第一排，旁边是一对现实生活中的夫妻，丹和亚伦，他们一起被预订在这集里饰演群演。剧组给了他们两个假婴儿。这真的很棒。你可以看到丹坐在詹妮旁边。当布莱恩·斯塔克饰演的愤怒的布法罗男人在大喊大叫时，他在嘘他的婴儿。他一直在说：嘘，嘘，嘘，嘘。别让生气的人惹你生气，宝贝。是的，完全正确。完全正确，完全正确。戴维·华尔斯暴怒。这不是他希望布法罗分公司发现这件事的方式。不，他说刚才有个小男孩问他爸爸在圣诞节时是不是会失业。迈克尔却说，嗯，他只是在考虑自己的礼物。这可帮不上迈克尔什么忙。斯克兰顿小组聚在一起。他们在野餐桌旁开会。梅雷迪思说，出于尊重，我觉得我们应该弃权认输。德怀特则说，现在人们比以往任何时候都更需要排球。奥斯卡——
agrees with Dwight, now they have this rallying call. They want to kick corporate's ass. Yeah, and they're doing great, especially Jim, which we get a little bit of... Petty Charles. Yes, Petty Charles. Petty Charles says, look who just woke up. And then scores a point and says, I've been up for a while. Okay, so now Dwight is going to stand up to Rolf. He is. And Jenna, I had one of those moments where I think I thought I heard something that's not in the script. It's not in the subtitles, and I need you to tell me what I heard. What? Yeah, exactly. Kevin says it's six to six.
同意德怀特的观点，现在他们有了这个战斗口号。他们想狠狠踢高层的屁股。是的，他们表现得很棒，尤其是吉姆，这让我们看到了一点……小肚鸡肠的查尔斯。是的，小肚鸡肠的查尔斯。小肚鸡肠的查尔斯说，看看谁刚醒。然后得了一分并说，我已经醒了好一会儿了。好了，现在德怀特要挺身对抗罗尔夫了。他确实这么做了。詹娜，我遇到了一个时刻，我觉得我好像听到了剧本里没有的东西。字幕里也没有，我需要你告诉我我听到了什么。什么？对，没错。凯文说现在是六比六。
It's a nail biter. Angela says Kevin, no, it's seven, six, or is that too much accounting for you? Rolf says, here's an accounting question for you. What does one fiancé plus one lover equal answer one whore? Dwight says, okay, knock it off, Rolf. Ralph says what? She is sitting here, casting aspirations, and Dwight goes, Ralford, please. Jenna, I swear I hear Dwight say Rolford, please.
比分咬得很紧。安吉拉说凯文，不，是七比六，还是说这对你来说算账太难了？罗尔夫说，这里有个会计问题要问你。一个未婚夫加一个情夫等于什么？答案是一个婊子。德怀特说，好了，适可而止吧，罗尔夫。罗尔夫说，什么？她坐在这里，居心叵测地指责别人，然后德怀特说，罗尔福，拜托。詹娜，我发誓我听到德怀特说罗尔福，拜托。
Meaning like Ralford is Rolf's full name? Yes. It's not documented anywhere. I'm probably just losing it. I need you to hear it. I'm going to play it. Ready? Okay.
意思是“罗尔福”是罗尔夫的全名吗？是的。这在任何地方都没有记载。我可能只是疯了。我需要你听一下。我要放这段音频。准备好了吗？好的。
Okay. Knock it off, Rolf. She's sitting there. Ralford, please. I am asking guys me. Oh, okay. Ralford, please. I'm telling you.
好吧。适可而止吧，罗尔夫。她坐在那里。罗尔福，拜托。我求你们了。哦，好吧。罗尔福，拜托。我跟你说。
Okay. The first thing I need to know is this. Is Rolf a name? That I don't know. Did we make that up or is it a name? Is Rolf short for Rolford? Well, there's a restaurant in Manhattan called Rolfs. It's in Gramercy Park.
好吧。我首先要知道的是这个。罗尔夫是个名字吗？这个我不知道。这是我们编造的还是本来就是个名字？罗尔夫是罗尔福的简称吗？嗯，曼哈顿有一家餐厅叫罗尔夫斯（Rolf's）。在格拉梅西公园。
Oh, here we go. Wikipedia. Rolf. It is a male given name and surname. It originates in the Germanic name Harulf. Interesting. But now, Ralford. Ralford.
哦，开始了。维基百科。罗尔夫。这是一个男名和姓氏。它起源于日耳曼语名字哈鲁尔夫（Harulf）。有趣。但是，现在，罗尔福。罗尔福。
We need background music for ladies who Google. We really do. Booty, boody. Okay, I will tell you, there is a... the Ralford Leather Company in the U.K. They are a supplier of fine quality leathers. Also, just from Ancestry.com, Michigan had the highest population of Ralford families in 1880. So I think you might be right. Both names seem to be names. I mean, just, come on. Okay, knock it off, Rolf.
我们需要为“谷歌女士”播放背景音乐。我们真的需要。布蒂，布蒂。好吧，我告诉你，英国有一家……罗尔福皮革公司。他们是优质皮革的供应商。另外，仅从Ancestry.com的数据来看，1880年密歇根州拥有最高人口比例的罗尔福家族。所以我想你是对的。这两个名字似乎都是真实的名字。我的意思是，拜托，得了吧。好吧，适可而止吧，罗尔夫。
She's sitting there. Castors, please. I think you're right. I think we have broken a big case here. mom detectives, we declare Rolford. Put it on your calendar. This is the first time Rolford is being documented. Yes. In the office, Cannon. Angela. I'm clapping for myself.
她坐在那里。卡斯托斯，拜托。我觉得你是对的。我想我们在这里破获了一个大案。妈妈侦探们，我们宣布发现“罗尔福”。把它写进你的日程表。这是第一次有记录的“罗尔福”。是的。办公室里的加农炮。安吉拉。我在为自己鼓掌。
A applause for you. Thank you. Good work. Thank you. And now to whoever does subtitles, change it to Rolford. Thank you very much. I'd like to say that that was a combo mom detective, two ladies who Google move. Do you see how both of those came together?
为你鼓掌。谢谢。干得好。谢谢。现在，无论谁负责做字幕，请把它改成罗尔福。非常感谢。我想说这绝对是妈妈侦探与两位谷歌女士的联手之作。你看到这两者是如何结合在一起的了吗？
It's beautiful, really. In that moment. I do. I'm proud of us. Ken shared that he really liked seeing Dwight softening to Angela. Angela's clearly moved by this. And then right after the scene, there would have been an Angela talking head. It got deleted, but I wanted you to hear it.
真的很美妙。在那一刻。我看到了。我为我们感到骄傲。肯分享说他真的很喜欢看到德怀特对安吉拉态度软化。安吉拉显然被这一幕打动了。然后就在这场戏之后，本来应该有一个安吉拉的采访镜头。它被删掉了，但我希望你们听听看。
Today, for the first time in months, Dwight nodded at me. And I have to admit, it made my heart sit up just a little straighter in its chair. I know I seem hard and cold on the outside, but on the inside, I'm as warm as porcelain. I'm sorry for gushing on like this. It just must be the apple juice talking or... I don't. It's very sweet. She is as soft as porcelain on the inside.
今天，几个月来第一次，德怀特对我点了点头。我必须承认，这让我的心在它的椅子上稍微坐直了一点。我知道我在外表上看起来坚强冷酷，但内心深处，我像瓷器一样温暖。抱歉我这样滔滔不绝。这一定是因为喝了苹果汁或者……我不知道。这非常甜蜜。她内心确实像瓷器一样柔软。
Apple juice is not on the drink menu. I knew you were going to say that. I also now like this expression of saying, it just made my heart sit up a little straighter in its chair. I loved that too. I thought it was cute. The game is going. And Pam is going to fall.
饮品单上可没有苹果汁。我就知道你会这么说。我也开始喜欢这种表达方式了，说什么“这让我的心在椅子上稍微坐直了一点”。我也很喜欢这个说法。我觉得它很可爱。比赛正在进行。而帕姆要摔倒了。
Lady, I did my own falling stunt. That's all me. I believed it. I'm very proud of it. It's not the first time you fall in this episode. You fall twice. I do? Yeah.
女士们，我自己的摔倒特技是我自己完成的。全是我自己来的。我相信了。我为此感到非常骄傲。这不是你在这集中第一次摔倒。你摔倒了两次。我摔倒了吗？对。
You had a spontaneous fall while you were playing fake volleyball earlier in the episode. Oh. I clocked it. You went down to your knees to get a ball. Huh. Mm-hmm. I'm a pro. You are sporty, Pam.
你在本集前面假装打排球时，曾有过一次突然的摔倒。哦。我注意到了。你跪倒在地上为了接一个球。哈。嗯哼。我是个专业人士。你很有运动细胞，帕姆。
Well, there had been a lot of discussion about using my double. and shooting the fall from behind. But Kent said to sell it, they really needed to see my face on camera. And it wasn't the shoulder rotation. Yes, there was no reason why they couldn't just have me fall. It was not going to affect my shoulder. Randy told me that sometimes in movies, they will use a stunt double from the front, and then they do CGI face replacement.
嗯，当时关于是否使用替身并从后面拍摄摔倒镜头有过很多讨论。但肯说为了呈现真实感，他们真的需要在镜头前看到我的脸。而且这跟肩膀旋转无关。是的，他们完全没有理由不能让我直接摔倒。这不会影响我的肩膀。兰迪告诉我，有时候在电影中，他们会从正面使用特技替身，然后进行CGI面部替换。
What? Yeah. Is this face off? Kind of like the movie magic version of face off. He said we could not afford that. So there was no putting my face on her face. Okay. So you know, at the end of this, when Pam is going to leave to get her ankle checked,
什么？是的。这是《变脸》吗？有点像电影特效版的《变脸》。他说我们负担不起那个。所以没法把我的脸换到她的脸上。好吧。所以你知道的，在这集最后，当帕姆要离开去检查脚踝时——
Dwight has to start stalling for time. And the first thing he does is he, like, kicks the volleyball really far away. This reminded me of, like, the butthole kid growing up, like when you played kickball, who would have a tantrum and kick the ball real far. Totally. And someone had to go get it. Well, we had a fan catch from. Emily H. in Ohio who said,
德怀特不得不开始拖延时间。他做的第一件事就是像这样，把排球踢得远远的。这让我想起，像小时候玩踢球游戏时那种发脾气把球踢得很远的大屁股小孩。完全是这样。然后得有人去把球捡回来。好吧，我们收到了来自俄亥俄州的埃米莉·H的粉丝留言，她说——
I have a background catch at 16 minutes 55 seconds. When Dwight kicks the volleyball away to stall the game, there are some weird face cutout board picture things in the background, and I think there is a person sticking their head through one of them. Really? I saw those things. They look like something from a carnival. All right. I don't know if this is related, but Jenny Tan wrote this in her diary for the day. She said, during the first few takes of Dwight kicking the ball, there was a background performer hiding in the shack. And whenever the volleyball was kicked near it, this person would wave his arm outside the shack and ruin the take.
我在16分55秒处发现了一个背景彩蛋。当德怀特把排球踢飞以拖延比赛时，背景里有一些奇怪的挖洞人脸板道具，我觉得有人把头伸进其中一个洞里了。真的吗？我看到那些东西了。它们看起来像是嘉年华上的东西。好吧。我不知道这是否有关，但詹妮·坦在当天的日记中写道：她说，在德怀特踢球的前几次拍摄中，有一个背景演员藏在棚屋里。每当排球被踢到附近时，这个人就会在棚屋外面挥舞手臂，把镜头给毁了。
She said, needless to say, this person was asked to leave the set and was told not to return for the rest of the week. I don't know. What's happening? I don't know. I was like, could that be the person whose face was in the little, like, picture thing? Well, you know, I'm going to go back and look. I know. Well, not in the shack waving their arms or Michael and Holly.
她说，不用说，这个人被要求离开片场，并被告知本周其余时间都不准再回来。我不知道。这到底是怎么回事？我不知道。我想，那会不会就是那个把脸塞进小画框道具里的人呢？好吧，你知道的，我要回去看看。我懂。好吧，不是在棚屋里挥舞手臂的那个，而是迈克尔和霍莉的——
How's that for a transition? I like that. We should share with you guys. We often wonder how to transition. We are trying so hard not to have every transition be lady. Lady are well. Yes. Oh, the wells.
这个转场怎么样？我喜欢这个。我们应该和你们分享一下。我们经常琢磨该怎么转场。我们极力避免每一次转场都用“女士”开头。女士们过得很好。是的。哦，那些“嗯”。
The wells. We do a lot of wells. Dr. Peter Thibodeau. Please don't count the wells. Oh, don't. Oh, I have Dr. Tibido a few times and it was staggering. Anyways, Michael and Holly are going to reflect on their skit and on their mistake of mentioning the Buffalo thing. And they have this very sweet couplet of dialogue.
那些“嗯”。我们用了超多“嗯”。彼得·蒂博代（Peter Thibodeau）医生。请不要统计我们用了多少个“嗯”。哦，别数。哦，我有好几次提到蒂博代医生，那次数简直惊人。不管怎样，迈克尔和霍莉要反思他们的短剧以及他们提到布法罗分公司这一错误。他们有一段非常甜蜜的对白。
Holly says, well, I'm glad we did it. Michael says, me too. And there's a long pause. And he says, we have a lot of good material for next year's sketch. And she lights up and says, I can't wait. Mm-hmm. Well, this was a really beautiful performance by Stephen Amy. They shared in the DVD that everyone at Video Village where they were watching the playback was crying.
霍莉说，嗯，我很高兴我们演了。迈克尔说，我也是。然后是一段长久的沉默。接着他说，我们为明年的小品准备了很多好素材。然后她双眼放光地说，我等不及了。嗯哼。好吧，这是史蒂夫和艾米非常精彩的表演。他们在DVD中分享说，在监视器前观看回放的视频村（Video Village）里的所有人都哭了。
They said Ginny was there, Ginny Tan, she was crying. And then Ken said something I just loved about this scene between Steve and Amy. I wrote it down verbatim and I want to read it to you. Okay. Ken said, it's the toughest kind of scene because in a way everything is happening and nothing is happening. all at once. There's a gigantic shift that takes place, but it's all under the surface, and the challenge is to find it over and over again, take after take, as if they've never been there. Yeah. I just thought that was really well said, because every time they did it, they had to have
他们说詹妮当时也在那里，詹妮·坦，她在哭。然后肯说了一段我特别喜欢的话，是关于史蒂夫和艾米之间的这场戏的。我一字不差地记下来了，想读给你们听。好吧。肯说，这是最难演的一种戏，因为在某种程度上，一切都在发生，又仿佛什么都没发生，所有这些都在同时进行。有一个巨大的转变发生了，但它完全在水面之下，而挑战在于，在一次又一次的拍摄中，一次又一次地找到它，就好像他们从来没有经历过一样。是的。我只是觉得这段话说得太好了，因为每次他们演的时候，他们都必须经历
that discovery of knowing that something just changed for both of them. It's a beautiful scene. And then they say goodbye. And then Michael has this fantastic talk. talking head where he says he didn't find the perfect moment that day to share those things with her, but it's okay because they're going to be one of those couples who have a long story. And he's just going to be patient. Yeah, Jen said in an interview that they loved setting up this idea that Michael was going to find a way at this picnic to try to make his move with Holly. But then, over the course of the day, as he spent time with her, he was reminded that they have something really special. And he gains this more mature way of looking at the relationship. And it's very different
那种发现，意识到对他们俩来说有些事情刚刚发生了改变。这是一场非常精彩的戏。然后他们道别了。接着迈克尔有一个绝妙的采访镜头，他说他今天没有找到完美的时刻来和她分享那些事情，但没关系，因为他们会成为那种拥有漫长故事的情侣。而他会保持耐心。是的，简在一次采访中说，他们很喜欢这样一种设定：迈克尔本来打算在这场野餐中找个机会向霍莉表白。但随后，在这一天的相处中，当他陪伴她时，他想起了他们之间拥有非常特别的东西。并且他以一种更成熟的眼光来看待这段关系。这与他面对简或过去任何其他女人时的行为有着天壤之别
than how he would behave if this were Jan or any other woman from his past. And that she said, quote, he was calm and confident and quieted by this thought. And I loved that. And this talking head right here is why you know this is his soup snake. Yeah. His soulmate. A hundred percent, right? Yeah. Well, Jim is going to take Pam to a local hospital and for whatever reason, they have this belief that Dwight can stall this volleyball game. I mean, for how long? I mean, have you ever gone to get an ankle checked or anything checked? Anything. Even just the commute and finding parking. and getting inside and signing up and getting your insurance information. I don't know.
并且她说，原话是：他表现得很平静、自信，并且被这种想法抚平了心绪。我太喜欢这个了。正是在这里的这段采访镜头，让你知道这就是他的“灵魂伴侣（soup snake）”。是的。他的真命天女。百分之百对吧？是的。好吧，吉姆要带帕姆去当地的医院，不管出于什么原因，他们竟然相信德怀特能拖延这场排球赛。我的意思是，能拖多久？我是说，你们去检查过脚踝或做过任何检查吗？任何检查。哪怕只是通勤、找停车位
Jim is feverishly filling out some hospital form while a sassy nurse is wheeling Pam away. The sassy nurse was played by Alison Martin. She sent a ton of television comedy, most recently Grace and Frankie. And she did an episode of Law & Order. Oh. We had a fan question from Christy H. in Maryland who said, My 13-year-old son thinks the hospital that Jim and Pam go to is the Scrubs Hospital. Is he right? He's a huge office fan. And Sam O from Milwaukee, Wisconsin said, at the end of this episode, you guys are clearly in the hospital from Scrubs. Do you remember anything about working there? Was the cast of the other show around at all? Well, I tell you what, Christy, your son is right. Sam, you are right. This was the hospital that they used on Scrubs. It is a former hospital. It's not even around anymore. They've torn it down. But,
进到里面、登记、填写保险信息。我不知道。吉姆正狂热地填写着某张医院表格，而一个态度傲慢的护士正推着帕姆走开。这个傲慢的护士由艾莉森·马丁（Alison Martin）饰演。她演过大量的电视喜剧，最近的是《格蕾丝和弗兰基》。她还演过一集《法律与秩序》。哦。我们收到了来自马里兰州克里斯蒂·H的粉丝提问，她说：我13岁的儿子认为吉姆和帕姆去的医院就是《实习医生风云》（Scrubs）里的那家医院。他是对的吗？他是个超级办公室迷。来自威斯康星州密尔沃基的萨姆·O说：在本集结束时，你们明显是在《实习医生风云》的那家医院里。你们还记得在那里工作的任何事情吗？其他剧组的人当时也在场吗？好吧，我告诉你们，克里斯蒂，你儿子说得对。萨姆，你是对的。这就是《实习医生风云》里用的那家医院。它是一所前医院。现在已经不存在了。已经被拆除了。但是，
at the time it was an abandoned hospital. It was the Riverside Community Hospital in Sherman Oaks. The Scrubs cast were not there that day, but Randy told us that their production graciously allowed us to use some of their pre-dressed corridors and examination rooms. And something I'll tell you is that we shot all of this hospital stuff on Monday. It was our very first day of shooting. It was before we ever went out to the company picnic. So all of that emotion was just day one. Day one. Wow. We started with the cold open, and then we relocated to the hospital, and Jenny recalled that she was not allowed to observe the hospital. She knew that we were going to a hospital, but she didn't know why. And we'll tell you more about that in just a little bit. I don't know how much longer Dwight can stall. The corporate team
在当时它是一所废弃的医院。那是位于谢尔曼奥克斯的河滨社区医院。《实习医生风云》剧组那天不在那里，但兰迪告诉我们，他们的制作团队非常慷慨地允许我们使用他们一些预先布置好的走廊和检查室。我要告诉你们的是，我们是在星期一拍摄所有这些医院戏的。那是我们拍摄的第一天。那是在我们去公司野餐之前。所以所有的情绪都只是第一天。第一天。哇。我们从片头冷开场开始，然后转移到医院，詹妮回忆说她不被允许去现场观察医院的拍摄。她知道我们要去医院，但她不知道为什么。我们过一会儿会详细告诉你们更多信息。我不知道德怀特还能拖延多久。高层团队
is insisting that Scranton put in their subs. And Dwight is doing this really long, roundabout thing of like, well, how many people must get hurt before a lesson is learned? One, two, three, four. He's doing a horrible job of stalling. But Jim is like, Dwight, keeps stalling. And then he gets called into the room where Pam is. And they get some pretty big news. But we can't hear it. Nope. But I think we know what it is. Yes. We got some mail. A lot of people wanted to know why was this scene silent. Obviously, they're being told that they're going to have a baby. Why couldn't we hear it? Well, this was partially inspired by the British show. There is a scene in that series where Tim is going to tell Don how he feels about her, but first he takes off his microphone. And Jen and
正坚持要求斯克兰顿换上替补队员。而德怀特正在兜一个非常长的圈子，说什么“在吸取教训之前必须有多少人受伤？一、二、三、四。”他拖延时间的技术简直烂透了。但吉姆却说：德怀特，继续拖延。然后他被叫进了帕姆所在的房间。他们得到了一个相当重大的消息。但我们听不到。没有。但我想我们知道那是什么。是的。我们收到了邮件。许多人想知道为什么这场戏是无声的。显然，他们被告知他们要有一个孩子了。为什么我们听不到呢？嗯，这部分受到了英国原版剧集的启发。该剧中有这样一个场景：蒂姆要告诉丹他对她的真实感觉，但首先他取下了麦克风。简和
Paul thought that this made that moment even more intimate. It's one of those things, kind of like the teapot note. There's nothing that you could write. that could ever meet people's expectations of what it needed to be. So if you leave it for people to fill in themselves, it'll always be the perfect note. I agree. And I feel like Randall Einhorn shared with us that the further you were away from a moment, the more intimate it feels to watch. Yeah. And so removing the sound makes you pretty far away. Yeah. Well, this idea was something we had been toying with for a long time. On casino night, there was a whole conversation about whether or not we should hear Jim tell Pam that he has feelings for her out in the parking lot. We ultimately decided
保罗认为这让那一刻变得更加亲密。这是那种让人觉得类似茶壶纸条的事情。没有什么东西是你写下来，能够满足人们对它应有期望的。所以如果你把它留给人们自己去脑补，它永远都会是完美的纸条。我同意。我觉得兰德里·艾恩霍恩（Randall Einhorn）曾跟我们分享过，你离一个时刻越远，观看时的感觉就会越亲密。是的。所以去掉声音会让你离得很远。是的。好吧，这个主意是我们琢磨了很久的事情。在赌场之夜那集，关于我们是否应该在停车场听到吉姆告诉帕姆他对她有感觉，曾有过大量的讨论。我们最终决定
to keep the audio for that. But, you know, we're going to do this again when Pam says goodbye to Michael. Every once in a while, it was a trick we could use because we were a documentary. We could pull the sound and make a really impactful moment. So Jim is going to run into the hallway now. He's going to call Dwight and he's going to say, send in the subs. We got mail. Annette E from Minnesota said, Jim's face, when he finds out he's going to be a father, gives me goosebumps every time he is acting goals in this scene. And Abby M from Utah said, what were the directions given to John for when he finds out about the baby? So, yeah, John Cresensky, man, why he didn't win an Emmy?
保留那段音频。但是，你知道的，当帕姆向迈克尔告别时，我们要再来一次。偶尔，这是一个我们可以使用的技巧，因为我们是一部纪录片。我们可以抽离声音，制造一个极具冲击力的时刻。所以吉姆现在要跑进走廊了。他要给德怀特打电话，说：派替补上场。我们收到邮件了。来自明尼苏达州的安妮特·E说：当吉姆得知自己要当父亲时，他的表情每次都让我起鸡皮疙瘩，他在这一场戏里的演技简直是教科书级别。来自犹他州的艾比·M说：对于得知孩子消息时的反应，约翰得到了什么样的指导？所以，是的，约翰·卡拉辛斯基，天哪，他为什么没有赢得艾美奖？
Why you didn't? Why the whole freaking cast didn't win more awards? because the show is delivering right here. Ken shared on the DVD commentary a note that he gave John for this scene, and I thought it was great, and I want you guys to hear it. The one thing I told John to remember is that over the course of this series, he's developed a relationship with the documentary camera operator. And so when John emerges from the room to make the call to Dwight,
为什么没有？为什么整个该死的演员阵容都没有赢得更多奖项？因为这部剧在这里完全在放大招。肯在DVD评论音轨中分享了一条他给约翰关于这场戏的指导，我觉得非常棒，我想让你们听听。我告诉约翰要记住的一件事是，在整部剧集的发展过程中，他和纪录片摄像师之间建立了一种关系。因此，当约翰从房间里出来给德怀特打电话时，
something about seeing his pal, the camera man. and kind of suddenly got him very choked up. Wow, what a great note. That's like... Yeah, that told me. This look. Because we debated whether or not he should be so wrapped up in the moment that he should ignore the camera, but in fact it was the opposite.
看到他的老朋友摄像师，不知怎么的，突然让他感到哽咽。哇，多棒的指导意见啊。这简直是……是的，这告诉我了。这个眼神。因为我们曾争论过他是否应该完全沉浸在当下而忽视摄像机，但事实上恰恰相反。
This look right there. It was almost like, you know, the cameraman has been sharing so much of what's going on with Jim. That, you know, that it became very important to acknowledge him here. So the look he is talking about happens at 20 minutes, 50 seconds. And you guys know these moments in your life where you're feeling all of this emotion and then you see a good friend. And it just comes pouring out of you. It's that person that says, are you okay when you're not okay? And I loved that.
就在这里的这个眼神。这几乎就像是，你知道的，摄像师一直与吉姆分享着那么多正在发生的事情。以至于，你知道的，在这里向他致意变得非常重要。所以他谈到的这个眼神出现在20分钟50秒处。你们一定也经历过生活中这样的时刻：当你感受到所有的情绪时，你看到了一个好朋友。然后它就从你内心倾泻而出了。就是那个在你并不好的时候问你“你还好吗”的那个人。我太喜欢这个了。
And I'm so glad that they had John as Jim look to camera and look to his friend. It's a brilliant note. That's great directing by Ken Kwapis and a great performance by John. And you too. Aw. I loved this moment. made me tear up again watching it. Well, we got a fan question from Kaylee and Auburn, New York.
我很高兴他们让饰演吉姆的约翰看向镜头，看向他的朋友。这是一个绝妙的指导。这是肯·奎皮斯（Ken Kwapis）出色的导演功力，也是约翰精湛的表演。还有你也是。噢。我太喜欢这个时刻了。看的时候又让我热泪盈眶了。好吧，我们收到了来自纽约州奥本的凯利的粉丝提问。
Jenna, did you have any idea before this episode that the writers were going to make Pam pregnant? And what were your thoughts when you found out? Well, I barely knew. They did not warn us like weeks or months ahead. I found out basically right before the table read. And I remember sitting in that table read. And Ken Quapis read the stage directions and there was like an audible gasp. in the room. Everyone was like,
詹娜，在这集之前，你有没有任何预感编剧会让帕姆怀孕？当你发现时，你的想法是什么？嗯，我几乎完全不知情。他们并没有提前几周或几个月警告我们。我基本上是在剧本围读会开始前不久才知道的。我记得坐在那次围读会上。肯·奎皮斯读了舞台说明，房间里发出了一种倒吸凉气的声音。每个人都像是——
So here is what the script said. This is what Ken read. The doctor tells Jim something, and we see Jim's face light up. Pam is also grinning. Jim and Pam hug. Jim walks out with a big smile on his face. So the script did not even say that Jim and Pam were going to have a baby, but everybody knew, oh my gosh, Jim and Pam are going to have a baby.
所以剧本上是这样写的。这就是肯读的内容。医生对吉姆说了些什么，然后我们看到吉姆的脸亮了起来。帕姆也在咧嘴笑。吉姆和帕姆拥抱。吉姆脸上带着灿烂的笑容走出来。所以剧本甚至都没有写明吉姆和帕姆要生个孩子，但每个人都知道，哦，天哪，吉姆和帕姆要生个孩子了。
But that was just for the table read. If you read the shooting draft for this episode, those scenes are omitted. It just says scene 51, 52, 53, see production for details. Yeah, they immediately took it out of all documentation, all scripts, everything. It was a huge secret. Uh, yeah. They shared on the commentary that our producers made a huge effort to keep this a secret. They didn't want it to get out to the audience.
但这只是为了剧本围读。如果你读这集的拍摄剧本，那些场景都被删掉了。上面只写着：场景51、52、53，详情见制作部门。是的，他们立刻从所有的文档、所有的剧本、所有的东西中把这删掉了。这是一个天大的秘密。哦，是的。他们在评论音轨中分享说，我们的制作人们为了保守这个秘密付出了巨大的努力。他们不想让观众提前知道。
They didn't want it to be ruined. they could not let NBC know. So crazy. So crazy. So none of the scripts had the final scenes, just like you said, right? And then the scripts that went out, they were omitted from those. And then every day, you guys, they would send NBC the CDs of the dailies of what we had shot that day. That's right.
他们不想让它被剧透。他们甚至不能让NBC知道。太疯狂了。太疯狂了。所以没有任何剧本包含最后的场景，就像你刚才说的那样，对吧？然后发出去的剧本里都把这些删掉了。然后每天，伙计们，他们会把我们那天拍摄的样片CD寄给NBC。没错。
It was deleted from that. Oh, my God. And then the final master cut of the whole episode that the network gets to review before it goes on the air, they had deleted it from those. they had deleted it from those as well. Oh my gosh. And then Jen said that all of the scripts, every single disc that was sent to NBC, they were all watermarked so that you couldn't copy them in any way. And Jen said in hindsight, if she was someone at NBC, she'd be like, they don't have her watermark her CDs or scripts. Like what's all the hullabaloo with the watermarking?
这些内容从样片里被删掉了。哦，天哪。然后是电视网在播出前审核的整集的最终母带剪辑版，他们也从里面把这些删掉了。他们也从那些版本里删掉了。哦，天哪。然后简说，所有的剧本，寄给NBC的每一张光盘，都带有水印，这样你就无法以任何方式复制它们。简事后说，如果她是NBC的工作人员，她会想：他们怎么不给她自己的光盘或剧本打水印呢？到处搞水印到底是在搞什么名堂？
That is so crazy. She said, in thinking about it, they watermarked scripts and CDs that didn't even have a scene to copy. It's so true. But they were just, I guess, so paranoid. Wow. But it didn't get out there, and it was a true surprise. It was. I guess when they finally had to, at the last minute, send the deliverable, airable version, they finally put the scene back in.
这太疯狂了。她说，回想起来，他们甚至对那些连可复制场景都没有的剧本和光盘都打了水印。确实如此。但我想他们当时实在是太偏执了。哇。不过消息并没有泄露出去，这真是一个巨大的惊喜。确实如此。我猜当他们在最后一分钟不得不交出可交付的、可播出的版本时，他们终于把那个场景加了回去。
That's right, but it was too late, you know, for anyone to ruin the surprise. or to even make promos. I think that was always their big fear, was that in order to tease the audience, yeah, that they would reveal, like, big plot points. And Greg was always so protective of that. All it would have taken is one, like NBC teaser of you and Jim in a hospital.
没错，但那时已经太晚了，任何人都不可能剧透惊喜了。甚至连宣传片都来不及做。我想这一直是他们最大的担忧，为了吊观众胃口，是的，他们会泄露像重大剧情转折这样的内容。格里格对这一点总是保护得严严实密。只需要一个NBC的预告片，里面出现你和吉姆在医院的画面。
Yes. That's it. And they'd have an announcer being like, Jim and Pam get the news of a lifetime on tonight's finale. Thursday, NBC. We got more mail about this. scene and I'm just going to just run through them real quick. Phoebe T from Indiana would like to know if I was actually pregnant or if it was just for the show. Phoebe, it was just for the show. I was not even
是的。那就够了。然后就会有一个旁白说：吉姆和帕姆在今晚的季终集里得到了千载难逢的消息。周四，锁定NBC。我们收到了更多关于这场戏的邮件，我只想快速浏览一下。来自印第安纳州的菲比·T想知道我当时是真的怀孕了，还是只是为了节目效果。菲比，这只是为了节目效果。我当时甚至还没
married to Lee yet, though we were dating and we were getting a little serious, but we weren't at baby yet. No, you weren't there yet. No. You were still in what I called the sexy life. We were in sexy life, and I will be wearing a faky belly in the upcoming season, and I'll tell you all about it. And then Luis from Washington said, why did the writers decide on Pam and Jim having a baby before getting married? You guys, that's just Greg. He liked to keep people on their toes. He liked to surprise the audience. And finally, Liz B from Columbus, Ohio said, what ended up happening with Pam's ankle? Liz, I love you. I love that in this whole episode, we have left you hanging about Pam's ankle. I feel you. This is how I feel when I watch a John Wick movie. He has lots of injuries.
和李结婚，虽然我们在约会，感情也变得有点认真，但我们还没到生孩子的阶段。不，你还没到那一步。不。你当时还处于我所说的“性感生活”阶段。我们正处于性感生活阶段，我将在接下来的几季里一直穿着假孕肚，我会把所有这些都告诉你们。然后来自华盛顿的路易斯说：为什么编剧决定让帕姆和吉姆在结婚前生个孩子？伙计们，这就是格里格的风格。他喜欢让大家保持紧张感。他喜欢给观众制造惊喜。最后，来自俄亥俄州哥伦布的莉兹·B说：帕姆的脚踝最后怎么样了？莉兹，我爱你。我喜欢这一整集直到最后都让我们悬着心惦记着帕姆的脚踝。我懂你。我看《疾速追杀》电影时就是这种感觉。他身上有那么多伤。他是怎么熬过每一天的？
How does he get through the day? I need them to be resolved. So Liz, it was just a slight sprain. It's just going to be a little rest, a little elevation, little ice. She's going to be fine. And that, my friends, was company picnic. I have one last thing to say. Is this goodbye to Charles Minor?
我需要这些事情得到解决。所以莉兹，那只是一次轻微的扭伤。只需要好好休息，把脚抬高一点，冷敷一下。她会没事的。而这，我的朋友们，就是公司野餐。我还有最后一件事要说。这是在跟查尔斯·迈纳道别吗？
I believe it is. Aw, Idris, you were fantastic. We really enjoyed rewatching all of your episodes. That's really fun. You were fun to work with. You sure were. Happy Company Picnic Day, everybody. We will be back next week, and we will be starting season six.
我想是的。噢，伊德里斯，你太棒了。我们真的很享受重温你的所有剧集。真的很有趣。和你合作很开心。你确实很棒。祝大家公司野餐日快乐，我们下周见，我们将开始第六季。
We are now officially halfway through our rewatch. I can't believe it. I can't believe it. It's flown by. It is flown by. We hope you have a great week. We hope you have a little bit of vacation Stanley in your day. And we'll be here next week.
我们现在正式完成了重温之旅的一半。我简直不敢相信。我简直不敢相信。时间过得太快了。时间飞逝。希望你们有个棒极了的一周。希望你们的生活中也能有点度假斯坦利的感觉。我们下周见。
See you then. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle. Our second drinks episodes are produced by Molly Nugent. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer.
到时见。到时见。感谢收听《办公室女士的第二杯》。本期节目最初是与Earwolf合作创作的。《办公室女士》是奥德赛（Audyssey）的节目，由詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的资深制作人是马特·比格尔（Matt Beagle）。我们的第二杯番外节目由莫莉·纽金特（Molly Nugent）制作。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗（Sam Kiefer）。
Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
奥德赛的执行制作人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯（Leah Reese Dennis）。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨（Bill Schultz）混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）的《橡胶树》。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。